Hello everybody.
Hello, hello everyone.
Oh my gosh, wait, the game's a little loud.
Let me turn that down a little bit.
Alright, so we have a little bit of bad news.
We don't know where Gumi is.
Um, and uh...
We don't know where she is right now.
We don't think she's awake.
That's like her only...
She's not in the VC.
She's, she's actually, she's not in the VC, guys.
So, so by the way, um, this is what I look like.
It's, we're all Halloween skins.
So this is what I look like right now.
I think I'm a vampire.
No, I'm a zombie.
I think I'm a zombie.
I think, no, one of our carries is not here.
I'm so scared.
So, um, so that is our, that is our first issue.
So there's Giga.
She's a mummy.
I'm a, I'm a zombie.
We're, we're, our team is like Halloween themed.
Um, I watched a video of what our games are gonna be like.
And like, um, the first three, the first three games sound so, so easy to understand.
And then they lost me after that.
And then I kept watching and then it lost, and then I got lost.
And then I was like, oh, wait, is this unlisted?
It's not.
Okay.
So this is what the games, this is, this is what the games are gonna be like.
I was gonna say, is this unlisted?
But it's not.
So like, that means you guys can see it too.
What the fuck?
Is that from the game?
Is there in-game music?
Is this, is this in-game music?
Okay, that like scared me.
I was like, what the fuck?
Okay, let me turn that down.
That's way too loud for in-game music.
Where's the rest of my team?
What's the, but yeah, you're gonna see the game, you watch the video and it was like, and it was like, I was like, oh, hey, ain't nothing so bad.
We go down.
I can do that going down.
We just jumped down until like, and the other one was like, oh, hey, like rob banks and robbers.
We just rob a bank.
And, and then, um, and, and then like, and I had to spoil myself because I didn't know how to fuck to play these games.
And I was like, oh, that's easy.
We just robbed the bank and then go back.
And then, and then it got weird.
And then, and then it got fucking weird.
And I was just like, what are these other games?
And I was like, looking at it, I was like, what the fuck?
What did these fancy words mean?
I'm so confused.
I was just like, wait, what?
I don't understand the last, like, four, three to four other games.
I don't even know which one is like the other games after that, because they all blurred in together.
So I was like, the fuck is that?
Like there's, there's ice underneath.
What do you mean there's ice?
What am I supposed to do with the ice underneath?
The classes?
What do you mean?
Oh, support classes now give you points.
But like, what, what am I supposed to do with that information?
Like, what is the objective?
And I'm just like, I was like, what the fuck?
And then I remembered, I asked like one of the organizers, I asked one of the organizers, and I was like, hey, is there like a practice map?
And they're like, well, people in your skill level tend to go in blind.
And no, we don't have any practice maps.
So we do, you can, I can take you to some like mini game maps.
So you can like play around with those.
And I was like, oh, I guess I go in blind then.
I'm just like, well, guess I'm just gonna experience it live.
Just...
All right, let me unmute myself real quick.
Hello?
Yo.
So I think, I think Gumi's asleep.
I don't think, I don't think she's alive.
So that's an issue because usually she's not alive at this hour.
Let me see if I can ping Snap.
Like, I don't actually...
I mean, I could call her.
Wait, has anyone called her yet?
No, no.
Yeah, I'll call her and see.
Because I don't know.
I don't know where the fuck she is.
All right, guys.
I've been like praying that either of them respond, but I messaged both and it happened.
All right, we're calling Gumi.
We're gonna wake her up.
She's on do not disturb.
So like, there's hope.
There's hope.
She's not answering, which is weird because that's usually my thing.
That's usually something I do.
Is Sound Guy live as well?
Oh wait, I could.
I could call her.
All right.
Oh, she's not answering.
Okay, I could call her cell phone.
All right, give me a sec, guys.
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna call her cell phone.
I could.
I'm gonna call an American phone right now.
I'm calling her cell phone now.
Well, you hear that?
I should mute this.
Okay, Gumi's awake.
Gumi's awake.
She thought it was 12.
She thought...
You're on stream, by the way.
You're on stream.
It's right now.
It's literally right now.
We're waiting for you.
Okay, okay.
It's like, we're all like, oh no, like, where is she?
But just so you know, you're on stream.
Don't say anything, but she's alive.
She's alive.
All right, we'll see you on the server.
All right, bye.
She's like, I thought it was supposed to be on 12.
I'm like, no, we're right here.
Okay, I called her cell phone.
She's awake.
She thought it was at 12.
She's... I called her cell phone, but she's here.
She's here.
She's getting on.
Let's go.
Okay, wait.
Perfect, perfect.
All right, so we don't need a sub.
We got Gumi in.
That's a crazy clutch.
I was about to get the Mr. President Poundcake who was on the toilet, so this is insane.
He's so good at these subs.
Mr. President Poundcake?
Is that a real person?
That's the best microspeeder in the world, by the way.
Oh, okay, wait.
Let me call Gumi again.
Let me... That was a lie, by the way.
You might be the worst.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm just saying, if we're gonna get the best Minecraft speedrunner, I think she'd understand.
No, the best microspeeder is on our team right now.
He's in the VC.
Oh, shit.
What?
No.
Oh, shit, you're number one?
I think the last two block wars, I had Purpled on my team, and every time he's like, hey, can you go into the chat and just say, this was Feinberg's fault?
He was saying it every time, and I was like, Jesus.
But I would do it.
But today, we flipped the script.
I have to find someone else to bother in chat after every round.
No, you can still blame him.
I think.
You can still...
If we lose... Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, every time we lose, it's his fault, remember?
He couldn't carry us hard enough.
Joe Bart did this.
It's like, why didn't you help us win?
It's never my fault.
Exactly.
It's never...
It's... We're not Minecraft players.
It's not our fault.
Like, they should know the risk when they invited us.
True, true.
Okay, but I go crazy in Blitz hunt for no reason, so...
The fuck is Blitz?
I'll carry you for one.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, I never played any of these minigames before, so what the fuck is Blitz?
Are you in game?
I can show you.
There's a... There's an area that literally has a all the games.
Oh, shit.
I don't remember where it is, though.
One sec.
Wait, where are you?
I can't tell.
There's so many names.
Hello.
Okay, there you go.
Hi.
I'm the skeleton guy.
Oh, wait, you're the... You're literally the organizer.
Wait, you can rig the matches, technically.
No!
Yes!
Let us win or you're never invited.
Okay, it's over here.
Hold on.
If you jump on this, you go...
Yeah.
Yeah, that's tip one.
How did you get so far?
I've been...
There's everything in the cave here.
Every game of all time is...
Okay, so... You got a lot of reading to do here.
Oh, wait, it's just reading?
It's not even...
Yeah, you just read it.
You said we get to try out the games.
Oh, did I say that?
You kind of did say it like that.
Yeah, you were like, oh, I can't wait to try out these games.
You take me there to fucking read.
How can you do this?
Oh my god, Gumi, no way!
I don't know how to read.
No, we not die, do I?
I have to read how to play these games.
Gumi, have you... You've done these... You've done block wars before, right?
Yeah.
Don't we have videos for it?
Okay, I'm the weakest link.
Okay, that's good.
There are videos, but that takes a bit long, maybe.
There are also tutorials for everything.
Okay, wait, I'll give you...
Are you the weakest link?
I'll give you the fastest intro ever.
Wait, you've played, right, Gumi?
Yes.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, so we're all right.
We'll be okay.
It's okay, it's fine.
Last time Gumi played, she did better than me, so...
Oh, that's great.
That's good to know.
Gumi, just so you know, I stopped them from replacing you.
I was there.
I clutched it for you.
Wow, you're my hero.
I was gonna get like a temporary sub until Gumi woke up, but Gumi woke up before I did.
My alarm just went off.
Oh my goodness.
That's awesome.
Thank god.
All right, let's see.
Wait, so what are the games...
Is this all the games we're playing today or just...
Okay, I thought it was like five.
This one is optional.
Well, not optional.
It's more like if we do really good, we play this one.
Okay, so the top two teams.
Okay, so I don't have to read that then.
It's not optional.
It's optional to win, but it's not optional to play.
We're gonna do it.
We could just send you into hero mode.
God, there's eight games.
Okay, okay.
All right, so like if...
It doesn't matter if I fuck up, right?
Like this is not that team oriented.
Okay, that's good.
I'm gonna be sweaty, but not mad.
You know what I mean?
Okay, that's good.
Because we all agreed to blame Feinberg in the end, right?
Yeah, I'm done.
I'm cool with that, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
How dare this professional Minecraft player can't carry me.
Is there any like thing in Minecraft that you're like good at?
Or have you played the game before?
Have you played this game?
That's a good question.
I think it's best that we go in thinking that I am like a newborn baby right now.
Wait, I know how to shift and I know how to run.
Okay, that's good.
That's a start.
I saw you play in, I think it was what, House of Nightmares?
Yeah, the Haunted House.
Yeah, we made it.
Goomy and I made it pretty far.
To be fair, it was Goomy dragging me to the finish line.
But I was ready to get knocked out, but she dragged me kicking and screaming.
Okay, wait.
Oh, we're waiting on HandsomeFella.
Where is that?
Oh, yeah, it's not even me.
It's not me.
It's chill though, like the event typically starts late.
I think I'm pissing off the admins.
You're pissing off the admins?
Which game is finished?
There's three admins watching me.
So we vote for the games, we're gonna get sent to like a dome.
It'll explain it in the intro.
We get sent to like a dome, you stand in a slice.
And then you vote for the game by standing in the slice.
However, there are sabotages.
You can get like a cat that counts for an extra vote.
You can get a knife, you can kill somebody.
Or you can spawn a monster that kills the entire lobby.
So we'll see.
Oh, ready check.
There you go.
Yeah, oh, and it'll show before each game, it'll show like a little video.
I thought there was like a coding going down game mode.
It's not even on here.
It's in party.
Oh, it's party?
Oh, that's party?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, there's like a mini game.
That's just four mini games.
Wolfie, I'm so excited for party, man.
I love the new, like the updated one.
It looks so good.
I thought this was...
I thought this was Sane's music for one second.
Yeah, we should check cook food for you.
Oh my god, there's Overcooked.
Yeah, Order Up is Overcooked.
Okay, here, I'll give you the games that they basically are.
So, Order Up is Overcooked.
Okay.
Party has that falling down one.
It also has Splatoon in it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's got Splatoon, so it looks so fun.
Yeah.
Blitz Hunt is Hide and Seek.
Extraction is...
It's just an extraction shooter.
You shoot people and then extract in the middle.
Shockwave is Valorant.
Well, that's Valorant, but you get frozen.
Extraction is the one where you take damage and die.
Yeah, Extraction is Death Valorant and Shockwave is Freeze Valorant.
Yes, plus it up.
I like Battle the most, actually.
Oh, I guess I'll never know what Spleef is.
I guess I'll never know.
If you die first round, you just do better the second round.
It's easy.
Okay, nice.
What the fuck?
Oh, I'm just stuck up here.
Okay.
Oh, it's like a POV of everything.
High technology cutscene.
Oh my god, that's so cool.
You can get one of these for every minigame, so at least you get like a primer on it.
Yeah, we get a multiplier to the game score, by the way, at the end of the games, like the later ones.
Yeah, higher, right?
Yeah, we get like slight increase.
I don't know what our best game is, so we're just gonna go with the flow.
Oh, I can move now, nice.
What the fuck is that?
Well, they took Parkour out, which I'm really glad about, because that's like my worst bane of my existence.
So, we're chilling.
Oh, you're gonna get an answer as well.
Hey, Doki, that's gonna be you.
Oh, that's gonna be me?
Where's me?
Yeah, hurry!
Oh, is it like...
Oh, let's go!
I said yay for Lee, because I've talked to him before, and then I realized I set a bad precedent, and I feel really bad if I just say yay to everybody else.
So, I just...
Btmc still has his Power Ranger from the last time.
He didn't change his skin at all, it's just yellow now.
Btmc still has pink hair.
Oh my God.
Everybody has custom skins, that's so cool.
Just for the event.
We got some as well, I think.
It's just like...
Oh my God, the Incredibles.
Yeah, ours are good.
You forgot about them?
Oh my God, wait, is this FNAF?
Yeah, they're FNAF.
They're like the Warden from Minecraft.
Oh, that's so cool.
They all slow turn, that was funny.
Oh, the...
Oh my God, they're in one piece.
Wait, no, they're half one piece.
No.
They're not coordinated.
What's this?
They're purple.
They're just purple?
Yeah.
How are we?
Spooky scary.
So, this is the dome where we vote.
Yeah.
Okay.
We have to vote...
It doesn't matter.
Yeah, it does not matter.
Yeah, we'll go in the thing.
If you get a funny item, use the funny item.
And if you don't, then you don't...
I don't know, man.
Like, you just play the...
Just walk around.
Just walk around, okay.
Oh, yeah, that can happen.
You can get burned by fire in this.
I don't know why.
Wait, but like, this is literally just picking a game though, isn't it?
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, it's because the order like slightly matters.
Like, the games at the very end give more team points.
But it like really doesn't matter.
Like, it does, but it doesn't.
So it's just like, whatever.
If you're like min-maxing, you try to influence...
Yeah, I don't care enough for it to matter.
Exactly.
Uh, yeah, I forgot that we're voting.
Okay, I got a cat.
Oh, I got a molotov.
How about a player grapple?
Is there a game that we think you want to get out early?
Wait, who's on my head?
I'm gonna kill everyone on battle, because I really want to get out of here.
Who did I kidnap?
I did not kidnap somebody.
Uh, I'll vote extraction.
But it's not gonna matter, because everyone votes order up.
Like, that happens every single round.
I'm going for tomb titans, guys.
That's right.
My freaking cat's leaving!
No!
Fire!
Look at that other cat.
There's a slime for a cat!
Ow, ow.
Yeah, there's one in can-man.
Who had?
There's a slime for some reason.
Order up?
Um, yeah, this is the cooking one.
I love this game.
Wolfie, did you use that light trigger when you played the last couple of times?
I used it last time, yeah.
Goodbye!
Okay, um, you should start with it.
This is overcooked, but like...
Ohio!
Yep.
Yeah, it's... I don't know why they did that.
Um...
I don't know either.
So, Wolfie and I are gonna start at...
are gonna basically play the whole game, like, at the crafting area.
And, like, smelt stuff and craft things and everything.
And the rest of you three will be collecting for, like, a majority of the game.
And then near the end we can, like, all work together because we'll just have way too much stuff.
Okay, so we're just collecting all the food and stuff for you.
Yeah, there's... there's all, like, fish, animals, uh, crops, like, leaves for apples.
Um, I think that's it.
Okay.
So, um, let's have Gumi do, like, the... all the animals.
Um, uh, Giga, you can do the crops.
All right.
And then Doki, you can kind of do a mix of both.
I know that's not, like, a good way to split it up.
Um...
Just do it based off of need.
You could call out what you need more of.
Yeah, yeah.
So I do crops and... what?
Crops and...
Just crops and animals.
Like, yeah, whatever... whatever's, like...
Okay.
Yeah, basically a little bit of everything.
Like, it'll... it'll reach a point where we have so much stuff.
But, like, having extras is really good because you can convert it into...
What is it starting, Elytra?
That's... that's for the delivery people.
Because we have to...
We do not... we do not have to kill the warden anymore.
So we don't have to do the... we have to deliver?
No, all you guys are going to do is you guys are going to spend all your time on this side of the farm.
This, like, collecting area.
And then you're going to come back and you're going to put the items in this chest in the middle.
And then Wolfie and I will handle all the order stuff.
All right, I'll just grab everything I can.
I'll just grab anything I can.
I'll start left.
I'm gonna go right.
If you log in.
All right, here, I'll go.
I got disconnected from the server.
Should I have some of the paws, or...?
It's not... ah, it's not a big deal.
It'd be cool if we got those.
Let's kill them?
Wait, how do I...
If you just kill them, it'll end up in your inventory.
Yeah, if you kill the animals, they should just end up.
And then the crops, you should just punch.
I don't have music, it's so quiet.
Use those red, uh, jump pads to get around, too.
You can, like, jump between all the crops.
I'll kill all of them.
Oh, wait, those are sheep.
They don't give any...
Okay, I'm gonna keep killing.
All right.
Yeah, just kill all the animals you see.
Having extras is never bad.
I'm heading back.
Yep, head back, and then put stuff in the chest.
And then by the time you get back, everything will be, like, respawned.
Yay!
Oh, I'll just keep killing...
I'll keep killing the cows and the pigs.
I'm getting a bunch of pumpkins right now.
Yeah, beautiful.
What are the first recipes?
What do you need?
All right, it does not matter right now.
We just have to, like, ramp up.
And then Wolfie and I will just go absolutely insane.
I assume you, uh, take care of the upgrades, fine?
Oh, yeah, I have a stack of mushrooms right now.
Okay, the sheep do give stuff.
Do give stuff.
Uh, can you work on the last order right now?
Okay, I now know!
I now know!
I'm a little bit laggy, but I'll work on it.
All right.
I can do the mushrooms, too.
I'm gonna...
I'll get the crops with you.
Oh, four, okay.
Come with me!
I'm gonna get pumpkins.
I got the wheat.
I'm gaming!
I got two cakes done.
I'm gonna run.
You're running on the paths to go faster.
I'll make another one there.
Okay, uh, it should be ready now.
Oh, shit, my shirt!
I gotta go, I'm gonna get the slime.
Oh, I'll get the mushrooms, too.
A shroom.
I can't see shit.
I brought, um...
Tons of stuff.
I'm farming, I'm farming.
We're just gonna make extra cakes, just so we have them.
Sure, sure, sure.
Unless we're...
Uh, I need to do one golden carrot, and then I can bring the second order.
Okay.
Here's some mushrooms.
Awesome.
Uh, I think we're a little low on fish.
Not that excited with you.
I got some fish!
I'm here to farm!
I also have some fish.
Amazing, amazing.
I figured people were just coming back with it.
That actually was a shame.
I'll make sure there will be no more fish in the ocean.
I'll make sure to get rid of Mr. Beast's legacy right here.
Get all the fish.
Fail.
Uh, okay.
Bread.
Oh my god, I can't get out!
We've got this.
You're chilling.
I'm helping.
You can pick her out.
Yeah, just take her, take her, take her.
Is there anything we need more of?
I'm a little bit discombobulated.
Uh, just everything always.
Okay.
Yeah, just keep doing rounds.
Okay, I'll make sure to kill these animals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just literally everything always.
I'm just gonna get a bunch of mushrooms, just for fun.
I gotta focus the composter real quick, Wolfie.
I got, I'll take care of the left order, order two.
Oh, it's done.
I'm gonna go crazy.
Oh my god.
My game is kinda tweaking, but we should be fine.
I'm heading over.
I said it like twice.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, rush order.
Uh, I'll make the pumpkin pie.
I'll get more fish.
More pumpkins.
Oh, that's how that works.
Okay, pumpkin pies.
Oh, I'm lagging.
Hello.
We're good.
You have the pumpkin pie?
I'll do the stew.
I'll do the stew and take that.
You're the director.
How are you lagging?
I don't know.
They hate the Netherlands.
Uh, you just need one pumpkin pie on the third order and you can take it also.
I can't open the chest.
I'm just waiting to get picked, probably.
Oh no.
Pause the game.
Pause the...
We're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Okay, you got rabbits.
Can you just slap random stuff in the top two furnaces?
Uh, I don't really have order in my hand yet.
We're winning right now, so we're chilling.
Oh shit.
This is why you're lagging.
You're doing too well.
I don't even know the reason why we're winning.
He's actually just hitting the lag switch.
Yeah, yeah, he's hitting the lag switch.
Everybody's lagging now.
Oh no.
Okay.
I'll do the rabbit stew, golden carrot one.
I'll check for the right order.
Do we have potatoes already?
Baked potato.
Uh, there should be some.
Oh wait, I don't have the cooking.
Oh, I'll get the sugar cane.
I grabbed like the whole snack.
I dropped out it on the floor now.
Oh, we're good actually.
Dropping off.
Cooked pork chop and chicken.
Like, we obviously need more meat.
This is delivering to Feinberg.
No way, holy moly.
Oh my god, nice.
This guy's hungry.
He's just cooking and ordering at the same time.
Wait a minute.
You're ordering for yourself for extra points?
Damn.
We get one.
Okay, this order's done too.
I freaking love fish.
Getting more mushroom.
It's like super close.
Like, everybody's super close.
Mm-hmm.
You'll see once the game ends that it's mostly the points that'll be different.
Like, the actual orders is pretty close.
But it like scales in points depending on how quick you are.
I see.
We need some apples if anyone...
I'm going over.
Oh, maybe I shouldn't go over because you get...
I'm kind of doing apples.
Yeah, yeah, I'll do it right for you too.
The potatoes are already in there.
Bread, I'll make some bread.
You make the bread.
I'll go over now.
You get the rest so I can...
Bread.
So they can have it.
Yeah.
Apple people coming in.
I'm waiting for more fish.
Fish time.
Man, I love fish.
I love the meals.
I love fish.
There's an instant order, Wolfie.
You can just go.
Let's go, Mills.
Let's go.
Let's go, man.
I love fish.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, let's go, yeah.
If only we got to name our own teams, man.
It would be so different.
Are we team Mills?
Yeah, we're team Mills.
We love fish.
Yeah, that's basically pink team, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, don't you guys...
Do you guys like Mills?
Um, Gumi, if you want to come back and start working on some orders, you can if you want to.
We have a lot of stuff.
If I was just not listening to the conversation.
Like, you know what?
No, I don't want to stay in my game.
I really can't add anything of value.
So, I'm just listening.
You could give your opinion.
You guys are talking about team Mills.
Like, I'm just listening and I'm silently agreeing.
I don't know.
Do you like them or not?
I'm okay with the name.
Oh, I don't know.
We need the sound, we need it.
Do you love fishes?
Oh, wait, we have an unoccupied smoker.
Hold on, let's put some shit in there.
I got something.
Oh, never mind.
This guy's already on it.
Okay, the right order should be done when there's a fish in there.
It needs one.
How do I deliver it?
All right, take the next fish.
Uh, right click the chest and then there's a...
Over here, Gumi?
No, no, we'll figure out how to do it.
Because we have a light choice.
Gumi, just cross up.
All right, I got more stuff for you guys.
It's much too late.
I'm delivering.
It's chill, it's chill.
I'm trying to see.
I can't open the furnace.
I'll get more fish.
I feel like we need more fish still.
Uh-huh.
Okay, hold on.
We need more everything.
This thing's done.
All right, is there any specific thing we need most of?
I honestly don't know if we need that much stuff anymore.
I think we should focus on making the orders.
Because we have overtime for delivering, right?
So just try to get them all done.
And then we deliver like at the end.
Okay, I don't know if I should...
I don't know if I can do that, but okay.
Nadia, you're good.
You got it.
You're a pro.
It's easy.
Let me look.
Hold on.
What?
Okay.
Right order.
Nice.
Too bright.
Can you look at the rush order?
I'm delivering.
Yeah, got it, got it, got it.
Mushroom stew.
I'm gonna do fish.
Yup.
I got the cookies.
Bread in the middle.
For three.
Okay, mushroom stew done.
Okay, I'll take it, I'll take it.
Okay, yup.
I know my purpose.
Chicken.
Okay, chicken for this one.
I think that's good.
Yup, chicken there done.
Okay, chicken's done.
More pumpkin pie?
Is there a mutton?
Okay, mutton's coming.
Slow.
Pumpkin pie.
Does anyone make it up?
Um...
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
A little bit more stuff real quick.
While everyone's working.
I have no idea what we need.
Doki, fish.
Oh, fish, fish.
I'll go, I'll go.
Order's done.
Reverse his legacy, reverse his legacy.
You're right.
He's got cancelled.
We gotta get rid of the fish now.
Our munchie bars aren't even good or whatever they're called.
It's time to burn the trees too.
Wolfie, you can deliver an order on the right.
I'm waiting.
I'm trying to complete an order.
Actually, waiting is so smart.
You're actually a genius.
Yeah, wait.
I'm gonna sit here and wait for the mutton.
We have the mutton.
Okay, wait, wait.
Put it in the chest.
Sorry, I took it.
Okay, that's ready.
We're not gonna get that in time.
Yeah, that mutton's not gonna be done in time.
Yeah, we gotta deliver then we're good.
Anyone delivering for you?
Hey, we did good.
We got first.
Do we?
Yeah.
Yeah, we're delivering too.
Where's my customer?
Mine's over here.
Bro is chilling up top.
He's got 20 seconds to deliver on, I believe in you.
It's fine, I got it.
There's one more chest here.
Oh, nice!
We can't like do it because...
Okay, cool.
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
Okay.
I'm giving the last one in in a second.
Nice.
And we're chilling.
Boom.
That game usually goes well.
I think I fixed the point gap too.
Oh my god, nice!
Oh my god, it's so close.
Yeah, the changes made sense.
Nevermind, it's not.
Just wait till the later rounds, the point gaps get crazy.
This one usually was pretty high point gap, but what I did is I just made it so when you do really good, you get less points now, which was the problem before.
So now it's balanced.
Yeah, the problem is that three teams would do like all evenly pretty good and all the other teams would just had nothing.
Correct.
Now it's chill.
Let's go.
Guys, we're going to all be top five.
Again, we can celebrate.
Oh my god.
I get to see myself up there for like at least 10 minutes.
It's going to be so cool.
Let's see who actually gets the number one.
It could be random.
I'm fifth.
Oh, nevermind.
I was fifth in the chat last round.
That's an E.
Huge team moment.
Why did you give me fifth?
Oh, yeah, I am definitely lagging.
It still has my normal skin.
That happened to me last event.
If you change it late, it just happens.
Oh my god, we're going to go for the beef, guys.
You could definitely still be lagging.
Like I'm not trying to downplay that, but that's a good server thing.
I'm for sure lagging.
I thought we were the milk lovers.
Okay, we can be both.
We can love fish and beef.
Get it together.
Which is it?
We have to pick one.
I think I only like fish, so...
You're tearing us apart.
But like...
That's it, I'm taking a nap.
Choices?
But I want it all.
I'm going to relog real quick.
Yeah, I am.
Oh, we have like a lens.
It's so funny seeing you with the normal skin up there.
One minute until our next game.
Oh my god, Mr. Incredible, I'm a big fan.
Where?
Hello?
I love the ones that did FNAF.
Oh!
Hey, that's crazy.
Wouldn't it be funny if you just changed the server to like EU for the next game?
That'd be pretty troll, yeah.
That'd be pretty funny.
No, I haven't changed it to Germany or something.
Wouldn't that nerf our entire team besides just me?
I'm East Coast at least.
Yeah, but like every other team will also get nerfed, because I assume there's not a lot of Europeans on right now.
No, yeah, there's not that many.
It's the risk we should take.
The most is, I think, orange with two, so...
Oh my god, I can read!
Oh my god, she couldn't read.
Oh no!
I just said one already?
I have a revival, so what are we going for?
What do I do for that?
I think we want to go for like...
I mean the thing is like...
I don't know what everyone wants to vote for the other teams.
I think extraction is not a bad idea to do early, because it's like one that usually is pretty tricky.
Oh, I got murdered, never mind.
Don't worry, I got you!
Brought you back!
Welcome back to your own world!
Okay, so it turns out that nobody likes fun, and we're playing the exact same game order as last time.
Yeah, yeah.
Because this was the same as last time.
How dare they!
Don't be sheep!
Wait, I think Fun also voted that too.
I think Fun voted for that.
Yeah, this one is Dark and Darker.
Fun, you're a fucking sheep!
I almost clicked the lead blockways button.
Oh no.
Wait, so how do you play this?
Uh, this is like...
Dark and Darker.
Yeah, like Dark and Darker, yeah.
Oh, okay.
So we can kill regular...
Oh, I'm by myself.
There's only like very specific zones you can fight other people.
So it's basically just like fighting mobs, punching these like things on the ground, like the pots, and just grabbing everything you can.
And just moving around a lot.
I will run off by myself.
It's a very not a team game, honestly.
No, okay.
Okay, so we should just explore by ourselves.
I will run off by myself.
Wolfie should go with...
Like, it is hard.
Like the mobs will kill you and that's really sad.
And then like you can't do anything.
Like your team can rez you, but you need to have someone with you.
So like Wolfie and Doki should probably go together.
And then Gumi and Giga should go together.
And I'll just like not die.
I am a little worried that I might be lagging.
So there's a chance a mob just completely combos the hell out of me.
And I won't be able to...
Doki, you have to protect him.
Doki is actually my carry.
All right, so it's nice knowing you.
It's really isn't it?
No, I understand.
I'm going to be left behind.
It's okay.
No, no.
That means we're both going to die.
But I will make sure to use you as bait first to live.
Oh, yeah.
Also.
So there's candles that help lead you to places.
The purple ones are the most important.
Because you need to go through a portal to like leave and score points.
Yeah, you have to do it at the end.
Otherwise you die.
All your stuff dies with you.
Oh, so it's dark and dark.
Purple candles are the limit.
Literally.
Yeah, it's like a 12 minute time limit.
Wow.
Okay.
So the candles are...
If you see one candle, you're a little far from it.
And then like two and then three, you're getting closer to it.
So you can kind of like use the number of candles in the stack to see what you're close to.
Okay.
Diane is a merchant to sell stuff.
And then green is puzzles.
Yep.
Though I've never found a puzzle in this game.
Oh, yeah.
Also, you can't sprint.
Fun fact.
Okay.
Yeah.
Good to know.
I'm gonna go left.
If Giga goes left, I go left.
Wait, where's Fun?
Oh, not Fun.
There's Wolfie.
Okay, there you go.
Like, I'm already split.
Hello.
Don't worry, I've got you.
Yup.
I'm good right now.
There we go, baby.
We can split like a tiny, tiny tad bit.
We don't have to be like magnets the entire time.
But we stick next to each other.
Oh, but there's monsters.
Yeah, but what if...
Oh my god.
He has a bow.
He has a bomb?
Wait, he does so much damage.
You guys probably have figured this out already.
But if you kill things, it's good.
They can give you better gear.
Like, you can very easily end up with full iron armor, which makes things a lot...
You make sure you actually put gear on.
Careful of this guy.
Oh, never mind, I killed him.
Okay, wait, I'll stick with you, Yuki.
Oh, there's an arrow guy right there.
We got him.
Oh, there's another arrow guy right here.
I'm beating him.
Don't worry, don't worry.
Easy work.
Oh my god, my hero.
Hold on, hold on.
You take, you take that.
You take that.
The trust block.
Oh, oh, I hate women.
Yo, I'm speaking my language.
Whoa, hold on.
Well, this arrow guy ain't shit.
Okay, I got pants for you.
Here, pants.
Oh, that was nice.
Kill him!
Oh my god, Kuri died.
Okay, Yuki, this is one where you can fight other players.
This room, the green one, is the one where if you see another player, they can swing you.
Okay.
Oh, so be careful.
There's also a mini boss in here.
I don't know how strong he is, though.
They can swing you.
Yeah, it's on sight.
Valorant guys.
Okay, all right, I don't...
Leather stuff.
Clay shards.
Yeah, you should basically hold everything that stacks.
Like, the things you should drop first if your inventory is full is gonna be like your leather armor.
Yep.
There's no team kill, right?
There's no friendly damage, right?
Yeah, we can't hit each other now.
Okay.
Oh, I have potion of regen and potion of healing.
Oh, nice.
Okay, let me just spleef myself.
That was awesome.
You know, I'm trusting you with the map.
All right, all right.
I was not... I've not been looking at the map.
This area is looted.
We can try to see if we can go to the mini boss.
I don't know if we're able to.
I don't know where mini boss is.
Like, we are in the chunk.
I just don't know if we have access to it.
Like, because we're at the top of the thing.
We might be able to go over here, actually.
Follow my lead.
Oh, should I increase my Minecraft brightness?
Probably, if you...
Yeah.
You can, yeah.
Well, like, you can up to, like, 100%, but past 100%.
Oh, I found some enemies.
Oh.
Some enemies.
Do not press the button on the middle thing.
That is, I think, the mini boss.
I don't want to die yet, so...
Okay.
So, I can, but not now.
Not this one.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there's other players.
Oh, the bomb.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm f****** going up now.
You don't have to go up, you're fine.
They're scared of us, too.
They're scared.
Oh, okay.
I'm going back down.
Here, take a stone sword.
A better sword.
Oh, we can open this.
Oh, there's a guy over here.
Okay.
Don't worry, we double team.
Big.
What's that glowing thing up there, Geeko?
Take a helmet.
This is a button.
Secret room.
Got it, nice.
There's someone above you.
He's got pants.
I see the players.
Oh, they're actually potting up.
Okay, wait, let's not do that.
Okay, wait, they're potting up?
If you just leave the room.
Oh my god, there's somebody.
No, let's go up, let's go up.
I'm heading up, let's heading up.
Debated.
We made...
That was on purpose.
We made you waste your shit.
Oh, wait.
I think they're already coming over.
No, I don't think so.
I don't think they activated...
Or maybe they did kill the boss already.
I can't tell.
I don't know if that was worth it at all.
They stanced up.
Oh my god.
Let's go, I think, over here.
Oh, somebody died.
Wait, when you die, it's just game over?
Or do they respawn?
You can get regenned by your teammates.
Oh, okay.
Hold on, I'm missing.
Oh, I'm lagging, I think.
Oh, no, you are.
Yeah, you are.
Uh-oh.
You can get it if you can...
Uh, do we have a good way down?
What?
Oh, there's a way down here.
You can get down this way.
Okay, be safe.
I hope I'm good.
I mean, Doki's got it covered here, but...
Yeah, let's go over here.
Let's go over here.
I'm going down to the bar.
Okay, I'm not lagging anymore.
I can hit things now.
Oh, thank god, yeah.
I saw you move, actually, for real.
Yup, I tried.
There are so many enemies here.
Oh, no.
Are we in a mini-boss room right now?
Is that what this is?
Or is this a merchant?
Oh, this is a merchant.
Oh, okay.
The green rooms, like the slightly green ones, are the mini-boss rooms.
Oh, what is this?
I pressed a button.
Oh, what did you do?
Hey, go over here.
There's a secret.
Oh, a secret!
There's so many buttons here.
I'm scared.
Let's do this one first.
Oh, it's like a little mini-maze.
Scary guy.
Is there anything else?
Yeah, there's a chest.
Oh, a big guy.
Wait, is he bad?
Oh, he's bad.
I'm looting.
Oh, that one.
I hate- Behind you!
What?
There's so many!
Behind you!
I'm gonna die, skis!
Oh, oh, they hate me!
Oh my god, there's a big boy.
Uh, let's see.
There's another button here.
Yeah, there's more.
Uh, I'm trying to see what loot we have.
Oh, I died!
Wait, you take the boots?
If you come to me, you can come to your grave.
Oh, no, wait.
Do you respawn?
No, you can just resurrect.
Oh, behind, behind.
Oh, that's right, that's right.
There's a full, like, if you, like, hold it.
I don't know if we, like, shift.
Was it E?
Oh, there we go, I got it, I got it, I got it.
You're good.
Okay, let's go over here.
There, there, there, there.
I forgot about the rest.
Okay.
Oh, there's more.
That's fine.
We're gamers.
We are gamers.
Ooh, okay, wait, you got an iron sword.
That's really good.
Oh, there's people.
I did?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, I did!
I found a button.
Wait, I have two iron swords, here.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, thank you.
I don't even know when I got the other one.
I didn't.
Uh, okay.
Uh, watch out.
This is gonna drop, I think.
It's probably worth it.
Okay.
There we go.
That's cool.
I didn't even know that's a thing.
Well, that's cool.
Okay, okay, okay.
Um, this is looted.
I think we should head over...
Wait, it was looted?
Someone was here?
No, no, we looted it.
Oh!
I was like, who's here?
And then you got to say it.
Yo, should I try to solo the miniboss, Wolfie?
Give me a yes or no.
Uh, fuck it.
Yes.
Uh, is this looted?
Oh, there's players here.
Okay.
Wait, and we can't kill each other.
Oh, hey, that's- he died there!
He died there!
You killed the merchant.
He's, like, above us.
I thought you wanted to find a player.
Okay, that sure was easy to tell.
Yeah.
Okay.
Isn't it, like, an iron golem or something?
Yeah, I, like, I smacked it and then I hit them with six hearts.
I backed up, got scared.
Can I steal their stuff?
Uh, you can, I think, open their inventory, yeah.
They can't, like- Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can open them.
You should open and steal their stuff.
Like, genuinely, you should steal their stuff.
Yeah, no, they, no, they, like, dropped stuff and then I, like, went over there to absorb some things.
Where do we go, where do we go?
Follow me, follow me, follow me.
Oh, there's stuff in here!
Yeah!
Oh, there's, like, an iron- I'll take that.
Hold on.
Oh my god, I'll take all of these.
Wait, I'll take the iron armor as well.
Whoa, thanks, guys!
While we're at it.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, that's perfect.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
Okay, I see a button here.
Yeah.
Oh, a guy.
Okay.
Okay, we'll go that way, we'll go this way.
That way, that way, that way.
I'm pretty sure they- have they done this already?
Since they died here?
No, this is not done yet.
This is- here's a chest.
Oh!
Yeah, let's go up top.
Is that a floating ladder?
What is this?
Oh, shit, I'm left!
Okay, um...
I'm scared.
How long do we have?
Oh, we have three minutes.
Should we...
I have not found a purple candle yet.
There's memes, there's memes, there's memes!
You can check your map, Giga.
The ones with the purple border are- Oh, they're calling us out for stealing his stuff!
Oh, I see, I see.
They said they came over and stole his stuff!
Okay, uh, we're going this way.
That's right, that's right, he came around.
But like- Over here, over here.
We didn't mean to, I swear.
Oh, there's more on the floor!
Wait, hold on, how much is this worth?
Three points?
Picking up our stuff!
This is worth more points than what I have in my inventory.
I'm grabbing the potions on the floor.
Wait, how do we...
Okay, wait, yeah, so...
Should we find a portal?
Yeah, we can go down here.
Let's drop.
I'm gonna drop.
Should I drop too?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can drop.
Okay.
Oh, I see another one of us in this chunk at the top.
Yes, me, what's up?
Yeah, there's three of you in there.
Hey, what's up?
I'm gonna throw this and a leather.
Uh, I'm like a little bit low.
Oh.
You and I are stuck with two people from red team.
I can't help.
Look at that, there's a good lover over there.
Okay.
Thank you.
I'm here...
Oh, wait, what the fuck?
What's the...
There's red next to us.
Oh, yeah, that's...
So that's decaying.
It's like...
It's like breaking.
Oh, there's lots of loot.
All right, let me get that.
Oh, I'll get that.
Don't worry, gay guy.
Grab the chest.
Should we try and find the portal now?
We have a minute and 40.
Yeah, you should.
You should have a good idea of where one is.
Do you have a good idea where one is?
I'm on one right now.
We can find one.
Yeah, just let's go down.
We can go down here.
Oh, maybe not.
No, don't.
Gaps are 10 points.
God, fuck, I'm chugging these.
Oh, we might find a puzzle here.
Wait, we might, we might.
Leveler?
Lever?
Wait, you said...
Okay, wait, let me see.
Here we go.
Oh, up here, up here, up here.
I think this should probably be...
Oh my god, what the fuck, this guy just dropped.
He dropped a ruby.
GG bro, I don't give a damn about that fucking guy.
Yeah, we found a merchant here.
Oh, okay.
If you go more up, there's one also.
Okay, we'll find it.
Right here, right here, yeah.
Yo, what's up squad?
Let's go!
Oh my god, are you okay?
We're good.
Me?
Yeah, you.
Oh, that was a shit night.
I get in with it.
Like, it's all good.
We can go through the portal.
We have 46 seconds.
I think we're good, yeah.
Um, should I go through, or...?
Uh...
I don't really have much.
Oh my gosh, spider.
I'm like, my inventory is like, pretty full.
Yeah, I think we go, probably.
Do I still...
Oh, so I don't have...
So it automatically sells when I go through?
I'm gonna drop coins.
This is for, like, max points.
Okay, goodbye.
Let's go.
Pick them up, pick that up, and stack it with your stuff, and then I'll grab these, like...
350 items!
Jesus!
Oh my god!
Okay, let's go in.
Bro, I had a hundred...
How much did I have?
I think I had like, 50?
Wait, how much did I have?
You know this when you watch.
Like, I just...
I get it done time and time again.
The miniboss is so easy to solo.
Yeah.
I mean, it gave me...
I probably had like, 50.
Wait, did we win?
Yeah, we cleared by far.
Oh my god!
That was crazy.
Gappington!
All right, let's see this individual scoring.
Come on.
TommyShelby3, do me proud.
I'm curious, I'm curious.
I'm curious, yeah, yeah.
How much did you get?
I just don't know.
I just don't know how different it is.
Not bad.
Oh my god.
Hey, Parker kind of went off though.
For a first time playing, that's huge.
Way to go!
Thank you for that performance.
What an individual!
Look at us!
It's because you gave me your coins, Giga.
That's all.
I did, I know.
You lifted me up.
And then they called me out in chat.
That was a 600 point experience.
Oh my god.
Let's go!
Yeah, but then like the multiplayer gets like harder, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like we could totally still like get absolutely crapped on, but this is a nice start.
It's a nice lead.
We're still up there.
What the heck, guys?
Nice?
Wait!
Look, I'm one point ahead of you, Giga!
Let's go!
My number's better, though.
You're right, you're right.
If you win the war, I won the battle.
Nice.
All right, I think those are the only fully team split games.
Never punished.
Twerked on somebody's grave and still won.
Feinberg, last time I checked, I didn't ask, so...
Whoa!
Battle Extraction are like the two remaining like team-team games, though.
Yeah, yeah.
And the others are just like a solo game?
Part is individual, race is individual.
They're all individual?
Spleef's individual.
Well, you can work with your teammates, but it's like not like a team-based game where like we're all winning together or losing together.
Oh, I see, I see.
Yeah, it's just like you get individually eliminated.
So if any of us make it further, we get three more points.
Wait, but Spleef is Splatoon.
Is that a team game?
The Splatoon one, party.
Yeah, that part of party is team split.
You're actually, yes.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know.
The heist one might be as well.
Heist is not.
Like, heist is individual.
You're just like dumping your points into the team box, right?
That's funny you say that, because I made the game and I don't know.
Yeah, I was gonna say, did you make...
Aren't you like the lead organizer?
And you're asking the players questions?
Like...
I'm just like, no, I just genuinely don't pay attention.
Interesting, interesting.
What kits do you guys usually take for battle?
We can talk about it when we get in there.
Are we doing beta?
Like an archer kind of kit.
We can, we can.
I don't know.
I just don't really care about what we play when.
Yeah, I'm down.
I'm down to stand on battle.
Yeah, sure.
You can see how good it is.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, golf rules, okay.
Golf rules, golf rules.
Leave, leave, leave, leave.
I'm gonna leave.
Stand on party.
I wanna play party last.
Okay, that's blue, okay.
Oh god, okay, okay.
I don't know what's happening.
We got Warcrabs and Lagundo.
Okay, the WCat duo.
No, I put my cat on battle.
I think we're gonna be playing Spleef?
We're playing Spleef, okay.
We're playing Spleef?
My cat!
You're just...
Nobody is in Spleef.
Yeah, we're playing Spleef.
Yeah, I was like, there's nobody in Spleef though.
Are we doing party?
I think we are.
Because it's golf rules.
So it's the one with the least is the one that gets picked.
Oh, the one with the least, oh.
Oh my god.
So many lingo.
There we go.
What the heck?
Alright, let's get it.
Golf?
What is this?
Okay, Spleef.
So you break blocks below people's feet.
Oh, it's Fall Guys!
Yeah, kinda.
Except you can break blocks under people and send them down.
Alright, guys.
I cannot wait to spectate all of this.
Sophie, I had a nightmare.
Yeah, you were gonna go crazy, I believe.
As a positive part of your...
Also, I got the most nervous for Spleef out of any game.
I got the most nervous for Spleef out of any game.
I'm traumatized by Joe Bart specifically...
...because he always walks up to me, looks me in the eyes...
...and then digs under me and I die.
It just happens like every time.
Why don't you just walk away?
Just go backwards.
Just walk away.
Have you ever heard of Jetski?
Walk away.
Right.
I'll do that next time.
You're so right.
This is also a social game.
So if someone's like mildly threatening...
...just press your crouch key and you're fine.
Okay.
Just press shift and then they might be friendly.
I think they would like run at you more.
Yes!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That's, that's, that's...
It's not nice, so they won't do it.
Don't do it.
Oh, I'm already a layer down.
This is awesome.
Me too.
That might have been my fault.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, the lag though.
Can I dig up?
Look above and you can start like...
Oh my god, that's fucking right!
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna dig up now.
No!
I dug up.
I'm gonna still dig up though.
I can't.
No!
I'm dead.
I need to stop digging up.
I need to stop.
This guy's emoting.
What is going on?
Hello?
It's just the guy breaking it down in his sleep.
Guys, I dug up.
I fucked up.
I dug up and I was not looking.
I'm just gonna make a wide stripe in the second to last one.
Let's not dig down for either.
No, I know.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna go social game right now.
I'm gonna go crouch at everybody.
Oh god.
Oh, he's coming over.
You're such a...
You're so mean!
Oh, that's not a friend.
Why is Kuroithon and Snowball at me?
He has one arm.
Like, dude, does he understand?
Yeah, he's just, he's just committed, man.
Wait, they can, they're throwing snowballs at me.
He's so mean.
No!
There's a red button too!
Stop fighting me!
I know.
Parker, Parker, Parker, Parker is not nice.
He is mean.
Stop!
Hold on.
Hello, you.
I'm gonna stay with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm getting...
I made so many friends here.
I'm getting terrorized by people.
Oh my god, Kuro got last.
Oh my god.
Just throw up.
Throw upward.
Oh no.
I'm making it my mission to go up with you now.
I can't believe the four split leaf allegations.
They're chaining at me!
I know, I know, I know!
Dude.
Oh, tragic.
I'm getting cyberbullied!
Somebody help!
I'm gonna kill this VTuber!
Wow, first Twitch and now this?
Oh no, it's...
Now I know why you didn't turn around.
Oh, I killed somebody.
Let's go.
I'm just trying to be a nice guy and it doesn't matter at all in my life.
Of course not, B!
No!
I got top layer on lock.
No comp.
Okay, me and Forsyth are friends.
This is good.
How do I freaking spectate?
Oh my god.
I'm just flat.
I'm just falling down.
Unlucky.
Hold on.
I'm holding it down for the pink team.
Wait, how do I...
Oh, I really got hit off.
I'm looking.
Hey guys.
I hope you're not believing my clutch.
Oh my god.
I see Gooby, hold on.
WT.
You guys are going crazy, let's go.
You see, this is where the top layer should be.
How did you guys become friends?
Wait, where are my...
Oh, my snowballs.
My snowballs just disappeared randomly.
Oh no.
Who do we have left?
Unlucky, man.
I got nobody.
I got 37th.
I just got full targeted.
It was crazy.
I'm like, I'm trying to consistently be a nice person and I just got full actual targeted.
Okay, this one, you get a bow and it explodes.
Oh, okay.
You can rocket jump.
And you can rocket jump with the bow.
She doesn't know what that means.
No, I know what rocket jump means.
That's from Team Rocket too.
The crossbow, you're gonna get a crossbow that like auto recharges.
The crossbow auto recharges.
You can like jump and then shoot and then you go high.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's kind of wicked.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I didn't mean to.
I'm gonna go for Luffy.
Come back here.
Oh, that's Toms.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I can like rocket jump here.
Oh, I see.
I see the rocket jump mechanic.
No, my god.
I just...
Oh my god.
I got all the way down.
I got to the last layer accidentally.
Oh, Jimmy.
Oh no.
I was testing out the rocket jump and I fell through.
Oh my god.
I fell through because I was testing out the rocket jump.
That make up box just combo'd me off the edge.
She's crazy of it.
Yeah, Blue doesn't like us for some reason.
Yeah, what the...
What did you do?
What did we do to Blue?
Hooster is the number one VTuber hater in the world.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah.
Certified.
He has a diploma for it.
Here we go for that guy.
Oh my god.
You can fall so far on those and it just doesn't matter.
I don't think I like this game mode.
I don't think...
I'm gonna get the switch.
Blue loves to...
Oh my god, I got knocked so far down.
I don't think I like this game mode, guys.
Hold on.
I got pushed.
If I did...
I should not have played around with rocket jump.
That was my...
That was my downfall.
Your hubris.
I literally was rocket jump and I fell all the way to the last layer.
I've done that.
That was a mistake.
Oh.
Camman18, noob.
Get Camman.
Get him.
No, oh my...
That's crazy.
I just play dropper.
Oh my god.
You actually threw the needle.
Oh my god, there's four T's.
That's still full party.
That's crazy.
Is it the more points you get for people being alive, right?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, sorry.
All right, hold up.
Time break master class.
You've only got the entire lobby on you.
They want you.
Yeah, they want you.
They know.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh my god.
The opposition.
The...
Oh my god, they're so good.
They're kind of worse, honestly.
Oh, blueberries.
Blueberries guy.
All good.
Get him.
Yeah, this is a...
This is a classic...
Fuck Meteor.
...not explain from me.
No, it's okay.
It's all right.
Oh.
They want pause for...
Pause for Jojo.
Yeah, somebody probably...
The gamer sounds a pretty good job, so...
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, no, we can...
This gamer is just...
This gamer is just bad, it seems.
Okay.
Now, I kind of love this game, but even if I die all the time...
It's fine.
It's...
You're gonna love this round.
You're gonna really like it.
This round is crazy.
So, this one is like Roblox natural disasters.
There's meteors that fall out of the sky and they blow up.
And you can pick up the meteor and throw it at people.
Wait, you can pick up the meteor and throw...
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
It'll like fall and then there's like a meteor chunk.
And if you throw it at someone, it's like a snowball.
But it deals like five times more knockback.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, yeah.
It's just goofy.
Okay, I believe.
I believe in us.
Hell, yeah.
I believe in Feinberg.
I have personal beef with you two now.
Okay.
Don't hit me up.
We can go for blue.
I'm okay with that.
That sounds like a good target.
I just...
I just want to live.
I want to be on the last layer one time.
I just want to be alive.
That's all I want.
All right, here we go.
I forgot the edges are thick.
The ice is all single layer.
Okay, so we can just stay at...
Just...
We just stay on the snow, right?
Uh, yeah.
But there's probably gonna be a lot of people there.
Yeah, it's like technically safer.
It'll probably be like pretty well contested.
So you might want to be careful.
Where's my friend?
Oh my god, people are so evil.
I owe someone.
Okay, wait.
I must locate the blue team.
Where are they at?
Me and someone from blue just like teamed up and dug some guy out.
Oh my god, that's fucked.
That's actually fucked, bro.
Wait, what's the red?
Is that the...
Is that the meteor?
Oh, that's the meteor stuff.
That's the meteor, yeah.
That's a warning.
It's a warning.
It'll come down from the sky.
Oh!
Ouch!
Yeah.
It's a meteor.
No, someone punched me off.
Hold on.
Oh, there's another meteor.
There's a meteor down below.
Where the blue team at?
I see one blue guy.
Oh, I see more blue guys.
You bastard!
You get back here!
I hate you!
I don't know who you are, but I hate you!
Sorry, someone just got like targeted in front of me.
And then I turn around and I get crouched down.
I was so confused.
It's like, oh, okay.
Guys, don't be...
Guys, peace.
World peace, guys.
World peace.
Oh, oh, I just did Fumble Nation.
World peace, everybody.
World peace.
What?
Oh my god.
Oh no, I just walked behind somebody who was walking over the ice.
And I broke the blocks in front of them.
Oh, that's so mean.
That's fucked.
Feels bad.
They're on blue.
It's fine.
It's all right.
That's what matters.
I don't have much to live for anyways.
So sad.
I'm not being aggressive.
If I don't aggress people, people will be nice to you.
Please be nice to me.
She just rocket jumped down a layer.
There's so many meteor chunks over here.
Hold on.
Catch.
Oh god, I want another one.
Oh no.
Catch.
Hey, where's that mecha blue person or whatever?
I need better ass.
Get her ass.
I need a tequila.
Oh.
I see Prince Zam.
Okay.
Prince Zam?
Prince Zam, yeah.
He's the op.
There's so many meteors.
He's the op, okay.
He's one of them at least.
He's on blue.
Wait, so what does having a meteor do?
Oh, you get to throw it at somebody.
It's strong.
I won't do that to you.
You should always keep, you should always keep moving.
Careful, the meteors are fast now.
Oh my god.
Yep.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, I died.
Okay, that was actually totally my bad.
I'm holding it.
I'm holding it out.
That's right.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, I like moved in a bad spot.
That was all skilled, terrible.
A meteor is actually really fun.
Yeah, okay.
That was all my fault.
Like, I was like at the very top and then you were like, the meteors go faster.
And I brought all the way down to the bottom.
They full target where you are.
So you just have to find like a running path that like doesn't overlap yourself ever.
Freak out first twice.
Not last, not last.
Let's go.
That shit was so brutal.
Some Mari Party-ass music right now.
Oh, the score breakdown.
Oh, thank god not last.
The difference points actually isn't that bad though.
Oh my god.
We should have beeped that person.
Blue team.
Yeah, blue went crazy.
They're going to be good in extraction, I think.
Oh, Galahad.
Yeah.
Who's there?
Oh, Galahad.
Still first, doesn't matter.
We're still first, let's go.
Gekko.
Joel's got, Joel's back on his hater guard, crazy.
Oh,
nevermind.
Oh, I felt my hater fingers moving.
I was about to type deserved.
Let's go, Wolfy.
Where did we go?
Oh shit, I'm still number two, even after that absolutely brutal game.
I got kicked out of the rankings.
I got kicked out of rankings because of Spleef.
Bro, that shit is brutal.
Oh, I got a 20.
We'll climb back, we'll climb back.
I'm 15th.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's like 16th in Spleef.
That's what I bring to the team.
I got 20th.
It's like, I'm mid, that's my goal.
No, I just like, I got four targeted by blue team round one.
If I just like, I need to drop, I need to drop the nice guy faster in Spleef.
Like, I'll start with a nice guy, but I need to drop it faster.
I'm still complacent.
I'm like, I'm not going to change someone's way of thinking, you know?
Like, they were throwing the first snowball, they were throwing the 10th, you know what I mean?
Like, I had to change that switch in my head and throw the snowballs back.
And then it was just...
No, it's not in my heart to do that.
It's not in my heart to do that.
I think I hate people.
Oh.
This is what Spleef causes.
I was about to talk smack to Curry for being in 38th, but he's playing with one arm, so never mind.
Wait, why is he playing with one arm?
Is it like a nerf?
His other one doesn't work anymore.
Oh, he broke his elbow at TwitchCon.
Oh, damn.
What did he do?
That's like, I don't even care if you broke your elbow.
Uh, the one where they said that.
I don't remember.
Where the guy turns around, he's like, look, I don't care that you broke your elbow.
It's Minecraft.
It's real life.
What is that?
Oh, I thought they were buttholes.
What?
What are you looking at?
The chat.
Okay, now we go for a PvP game, surely, right?
No, look, it kind of looks like a butthole.
Oh.
Oh, I got a cat.
Why do you want to put a cat, Stokie?
Battle, red, red, red, red, battle.
Okay.
Cat down.
Is that my cat?
Jimmy is keeping my cat hostage.
Wait, my cat's gone.
I got a catnip.
Oh, no, I'm getting mad.
I think I need to beat someone.
My cat.
Do it.
Let it out.
Goodbye.
Okay, I think we actually get that one.
Not allowed in the rest of the event.
Oh, my god, how did I die?
Oh, battle not on track, like, shocker.
This is an elite second half coming up, hold on.
I'm liking this.
Shocker.
Who is still, who is still punching me?
I cannot even exist right now.
I can't even exist.
Okay, so this one is kit pvp battle royale.
Oh, okay.
I know that.
Yeah, so we pick a kit that's like rolls.
It's kind of like Overwatch-ish in terms of kits.
I think fine will probably go damage.
I could go damage.
Gumi, you said you want to do range, right?
I can do support.
Yeah.
So, Gumi, you can go skeleton.
That's like the bow kit.
I think that would be good.
I'm looking at the summoner.
You like doing, do I get blocks?
Do you like doing two support or one?
Yeah, we should have two.
Two, yeah.
You guys get points for healing, too.
It's kind of awesome.
Yeah.
What do we, what should we pick for support?
There's like three characters.
Uh, I'd say fairy and medic are the easiest.
One of them's like, yeah, I think those two are the best one.
One of them's like god tier.
Fairy and medic at some point.
If fairy is crazy, I can play because I've played it before.
That's the one that's like, uh, if you just stand on me, you regen.
And then I can just buff that regen every now and then.
So we just pack up in one spot as best we can.
And medic is pretty simple.
You just throw a potion on people.
What does summoner do?
It summons like...
You can click it and see.
You're not locked.
You're not locked in when you click it.
What's medic healing?
You get, you get like...
Medic's just like a default kind of healing kit.
Fairy is like, has sort of an ability that we have to like, stay next to the fairy to get better healing.
Alright, are you playing scout?
Yeah, yeah, I'm playing scout.
Okay, I don't know what I want to play.
Um, I might go like trickster.
That'd be kind of silly.
What is on this kit?
I don't even know.
I don't know what they changed for the kits this time.
Uh, I don't think anything got changed from what I remember.
I don't think so, yeah.
But as long as, uh, one of you guys is fairy, one of you guys is medic.
And then both me and Goomy, you guys can kind of pick whatever.
Yeah.
And I will just make call-outs as to where we're going.
And if we all go together and we all die, it's my fault.
So just don't, just listen.
If we all listen to the wrong comm, it's better than like half of us being split.
And if we end up dying, it's my fault.
Okay, what if I assimilate?
What's happening here?
Come here.
Into another team?
It's probably still my fault.
Okay, noted.
Everyone jump on the dock.
Wait, oh.
Fuck, I forgot about the dock.
No, this is so important.
Come on.
Wait, is it good luck?
You have to.
I'll do it next round.
No, I did before though.
I did before.
That was so close.
Okay, uh, we have a medic, right?
So we can do the splash absorption at the start.
Yeah, sure.
Splash absorption.
Should I do it now or just wait for the start?
Let's just, let's play it, um...
Or wait, yeah.
Fine, you can just call.
Yeah, fine, fine.
Do it now, do it now, do it now.
Do the absorption.
Did I do it?
Um...
You have to throw it at the feet.
There we go.
All right, here, stay up, stay up, stay up.
We're gonna mullet off them.
There are some gaps.
Two teams here, stay up, stay up.
Hi, ground doki.
Hi, let's go.
We can clean up, we can clean up this fight.
Just use range, use range.
It said next to me if you are low, get on me.
I'll try to get you.
Don't worry, I've got the kill right here.
I'll be blasting them.
I got a kill.
Okay.
Look at this blue and orange fight.
Just try to spam them with arrows.
Don't worry, I exist to heal.
Someone's hurting me.
Oh, I have splash harming, hold on.
Yeah.
I'm going around the slider to spam them.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'll stay with.
Big.
Oh, that did big damage.
Hold on, cleanup crew.
Yeah, run, run.
Okay, okay.
Cam's low.
A blue behind is chasing.
No, they're no longer chasing.
Nice.
Everyone stay, just stay, stay, stay.
Come, come, come.
Try to get up this ladder if you can.
Yep.
Up the ladder I go.
Oh my god, up the ladder I go for real.
We don't have like people in range.
We didn't get a capture point, but I think we made up for it.
I'm sorry, let's just run at this orange person over here.
Okay, watch the void, watch the void, watch the void.
Be careful, be careful, yeah.
Watch the void, watch the void.
Yeah, don't fall, don't fall.
Watch the jumps here.
There's just a couple scary jumps.
I'm just trying to run at this orange person.
They just keep, uh, I think their team is telling them that they...
Oh my god, parkour civilization.
Someone hit me, I'm in the void.
Oh no!
No!
No, you're here!
Midair.
Yeah, midair.
I'm still here, I'm still here.
That's okay.
Yeah, we'll just stay up here.
Try to get up a ladder if you can, yeah.
Try to get up a ladder if you can.
Every jump you make counts, parkour civilization.
Are you gonna jump for the beef?
There's one solo blue.
I'm jumping for the beef!
I can spectate, I'll watch.
Get the harm, get the harm!
Uh, border shrink is soon-ish.
Yeah, we're up here, we're up here, we're chilling, we're chilling.
So yellow has two, light blue has two, green has two.
How many people are alive on orange?
Still one or zero?
One, one, one.
Thank you, thank you.
And then there's two full teams, red and blue.
Yeah, red is full.
Okay, okay, very wonderful.
Yeah, there's Kuriwa on the right, he's like solo, just chilling on the tower.
I'm jumping, orange is- orange on the slider, on the slider, on the slider!
Yeah, hold on, yeah, yeah, get him, get him, get him.
Unlucky.
No, we can take some space here, come down, come down, come down anyways.
I'm down here!
We want to try to fight the people that are solo.
That is true.
Yeah.
Oh my god, this soundtrack is so intense.
Actually, up the slider is not fine, because the two other teams are gonna shoot us.
Come back, come back, come back, come back, come back, come back, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Blue's going after us slowly.
Make sure you guys are healed up.
Fuck it.
All right, come in Wolfie, come in Wolfie.
Okay, you can see I'm up above our head.
All right, everyone come in, everyone come in, watch this.
We're gonna go down in this ice and we're just gonna start fighting people.
Come down this ice and just go around the ring of death, do it.
The ice of death!
Just don't touch anything.
Just go!
Some Looney Tunes-ass gameplay right here.
I'm trying, but I'm scared!
This guy can't sprint jump because he has one arm.
Taking advantage.
Oh god.
That was a goofy, goofy little play there.
Thank you.
Okay, careful of the border.
You guys just have to zoom down there with you, three.
There's 16.
All right, more people dropping.
Hold on, I'll find one on you right now.
I don't have heals yet.
Can you heal me, heal me, heal me, can you splash it down?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I splashed one down.
Oh, it's over time.
I might be dead though, I might be dead.
Go center, go center.
They all come up to me.
Oh god, that was purple.
I couldn't tell.
I hate women!
Okay, hold on.
Yeah, that actually was purple.
That actually was purple.
I couldn't tell.
I'm not even gonna ask you.
I couldn't tell because that color looked like our color.
That was so similar.
Yeah, I was like, team!
And then I got hit.
That was good though.
That was honestly really good.
Our dance there was good, yeah.
I liked it.
That was three percent of the damage.
I was so sad, they shot me midair.
Hold on, I had eight.
That's crazy.
I was just blasting the firework.
No, the firework crest was funny.
How much healing did you guys do percentage-wise?
I've just never seen it before.
Does it say in the chat?
Like percentage of total healing?
I've never, this is a new mechanic, so I'm just curious.
If it doesn't, that's okay.
It says I did, oh, I did.
I did 7.8.
I did, is that good?
I only got 0.3.
Probably, yeah, probably.
That's okay.
I don't know if that's good.
I got plus, plus 20.
I don't know if it's good either.
Yeah, I got plus 23 points for it.
I'm on the dock.
Why?
I'm jumping, I'm jumping.
If you could change your weight, would ya?
Who's turn is it?
So, we have Awk on our right.
We're gonna go right, we're gonna go right, we're gonna go right.
We're gonna do the absorption at the very start, we're gonna go right.
Okay, splash absorption, okay.
We're going, okay, Ducky, throw it on the floor.
I do it, I'm doing it, I'm doing it.
Let's go.
And now we're going right.
Yeah, we wanna contest, I think, for capture point.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
We wanna contest this fight.
Try to stay up if you can.
Like, get up on this ladder, Wolfie.
I'm dropping down here, and I'm blasting him.
Okay, I'm going up on the ladder.
I'm going up the ladder too.
Stay with you.
Okay, moxwomb down.
Oh, you fucking...
Let's pick off this one, the small orange.
I just... that's my bad.
I didn't... I wasn't thinking.
Your center, your center.
Can you guys all come?
Ducky and I are holding height, though.
Is that okay?
We're gonna come back up, we're gonna come back up, we're gonna come back up.
I'm staying up here.
Oh, wait, we're still capturing.
It's chilled out.
It captures when you...
All right, let's just get up, let's just get up.
I don't know where another ladder is.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, I got lost.
Yellow is coming, yellow is coming behind us.
Careful.
They're not gonna actually fight.
Purple's chilling, green and red are fighting over to the right.
We can try to clean up.
There's an orange to my right.
I'm watching left, I'm watching yellow.
I am existing, I'm existing.
There's yellow to our left.
I wanna try to jump green maybe if this gets ugly.
I don't know.
I'm getting...
Maybe if it gets ugly.
One yellow's heading toward us.
I'm gonna try to go behind orange here.
I'm gonna try to go behind orange.
Okay, okay, okay.
They're looking at us.
Where is that?
Oh, we are not here.
I was looking the wrong way.
Can we go over to you?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wolfie back up.
Oh, this guy's committed.
He's mad.
Okay, I need healing.
He ran away from me.
Camp's on me.
Don't worry, I got you.
He's gonna back up and they're all gonna back up.
Pop to regen.
Now what?
Yeah, pop a healing pot on all of us together if we group up here.
I'll give you a harming too just in case they push up.
Okay.
I have my healing pot regening right now.
Hey, watch the void.
Watch the void.
Careful.
I didn't want to get shot off like you.
Back up, watch the void.
Just don't get shot.
Yeah, jump over here.
Jump over here.
I'm like, I don't want to be like Keegan like last game.
Exactly.
Okay, hold on.
Purple over here, we can like...
Purple is poking?
No, no, we should just chill, we should just chill.
You should save your rocket things.
I have one...
Okay, one red, one blue, one aqua, one lime.
Who's on eighth?
Is there a person alive on orange or no?
There's three.
Let's jump all across.
And then just chill here.
Oh my god.
I'm so chill, I feel so chill.
I'm watching.
I'm just flashing blue a little bit.
I'm going to shoot yellow over there.
I'm looking at your HP.
I'm standing on you.
I'm existing, I'm Lucio-ing.
I'm moving, I'm moving, I'm making a tiny circle.
I'm healing.
Oh no, we can just stand over here.
These mobs are annoying as shit.
I need to be on healing, yo.
I have an instant heal, just in case.
Alright, let's all go down into the ice.
Ready?
3, 2, 1, go, go, jump down.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Jumping down?
I'm ouchie.
Oh god.
My kit's so not great on close range.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god, what is...
Oh, it's overtime, it's overtime.
What is going on?
I'm so low, I'm so low.
I couldn't do it.
You got this, you got this, you're doing good.
Let's go, let's go squad, let's go squad.
Stay, stay middle, yep.
Nice!
Let's go!
Alright.
I did 10.88.
Be sad, be sad.
We're in first again.
12.29% Epic.
You can pick whatever, honestly.
Whatever.
Flex slots.
My mental game plan doesn't have a good fifth kit.
That I know is better than the rest of them.
So you can pick whatever you're most comfortable with.
Back on the leaderboards we go.
Let's go.
It matters in the sense that whatever you think you'll do the best with.
Not in the sense that this kit is so good you should pick it every time.
That's all.
Wait, how many rounds of this?
Oh, one more.
Oh, I see it, round 303.
Got him.
Rofi, it's actually criminal I got 27 that one time.
I'm putting it on my mind.
This round I have 14.
I have to double that to beat that.
It's actually insane what happened.
A what?
27 kills in one?
Yeah, yeah.
I activated the sleeper agents in my team.
I feel like I should have asked ahead of time.
Do my summoning mobs hurt us?
No, just other people.
They distract other people.
Oh, I see.
They're pretty good.
What we had literally last round.
When you're in a corner, those mobs can...
Yeah, I was down to 5 hearts for nothing.
Same, yeah.
I was just kind of chilling there.
Yay!
Let's go!
I have the instant health potion so I'll just keep that in the last fight if we need it.
Bubblegut.
That damage combo is crazy.
What happens...
You know the end circle where everyone starts mosh pitting?
Yeah, yeah.
Your kit gets taken away there so you gotta use all your stuff.
Oh, so there's no heals or anything.
It's just fight.
Oh, I see.
It's just everyone's on the equal playing ground.
I think it's full healed back.
At the very end, I don't think you get full healed but everyone gets set to 5 hearts max and you have leather armor, stone sword.
And the end game is so funny because if you get a kill you heal either a heart or a heart and a half.
So hitting the last 10 people not only is good for points but it just lets you chain fights.
Like, I was on one heart and I swapped over to another 1v1 and just got a last hit on somebody and then killed the guy that they were fighting.
Oh, that makes so much more sense.
Yeah, yeah.
It enables a lot of the really cool clips because people can just stay alive longer than they should.
So I think it's a cool feature even if it's not the most fair.
I mean, it's only one heart.
It's just to extend your living situation for one second.
Maybe it's two hearts.
My chat's correcting me and they love it more than I do.
Yeah, they love the game more than you do.
Believe it or not.
Crazy.
Insane.
You're just the one to put it on display.
In reality, your chat's actually the one getting first in the...
Orange...
and...
Pink or purple.
Let's go right again.
But not right away.
Actually, let's just go right away.
Yeah, let's just go.
I keep expecting all these teams to be ready for a flank and they just never are.
No, no, get on the ladder.
Get on the ladder up here.
Let these teams fight over it and then we can... Oh my god, look!
Oh, he jumped.
I'm gonna come up.
I'm going up.
Nice, blue just below.
Be careful.
Oh my god, you're so far.
Are you okay?
Will you be okay?
Yeah, yeah, I'll be fine.
Get him!
I really dislike this person.
I'm gonna come back to you guys.
You guys just chill.
Get him, chicken!
You need heals down there?
Wait, I can just throw this on them.
Purple, purple behind us!
Purple behind us!
Purple behind?
Okay, okay, okay.
Fuck, I don't know what to do.
Stay up, stay up.
You can jump, you can jump down if you need to.
We can all jump down.
Everyone jump all the way down to the middle.
All the way down to the middle.
We're gonna have fun on the ice, we're gonna have fun on the ice.
We like the ice.
Nice heal, nice heal!
Went so bad, oh my god.
I'm throwing insta-heals for you guys.
Oh god.
I skipped the ice, I'm coming back.
Smoke bomb.
This is tough.
This is cucked, this is cucked.
I'm getting chased down.
Wait, I want this.
I'm trying to target the people in low armor.
Cause the diamond, like you can't crit down here.
Who's chasing me?
Brother, come back!
Come back, I have a delivery for you, man!
I'm trying to heal you guys!
Let me live!
I'm living!
I'm trying to get you!
She got chased!
Pan is just like, what the fuck is this guy?
I know, we're going so fast.
We're going so fast, I'm trying to make sure to get to you guys.
Yeah, so this ice play is genuinely not the move, but I know that now, Elise.
But it's fun.
Oh my god, there's blue and green here!
Shooting seven on the ice, I'm trying to catch him off.
Don't kill someone!
I'm trying to keep making sure he's dead!
Hold on, I'm coming, I'm looping back in.
There's a green guy.
We'll go the other side, that's where I'm going to cut you off.
I'm 45 degree ice skating, this is insane.
Foot on three, foot on three, foot on three!
I'm going to cut you off.
It throws us on like, one HP as well.
Yeah, it's just like, dying, dying.
Don't worry, I'm going to cut them off.
Get him, get him, get him!
I love skill-based gameplay, this is awesome.
Are you guys okay?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I'm trying to chase Forest down here.
Yeah, this is my opportunity.
I'm going to go the other way.
Okay, I stopped him.
Oh my god, okay, I'm going the other way again!
I'm going the other way!
I blasted him.
I'm going the other way as well.
Six, six, six, six, six!
I did it, I missed!
Five HP, five HP!
I swear to god.
Where is he?
I'm going to get him, I'm going to get him.
Nice!
We should have grouped together.
On me, on me, on me.
Regen, pop the big regen.
Okay.
You're scaring me.
What the fuck was that play?
Come over to the right here, come over to the right here.
Bet.
Okay, okay, okay.
More points.
Alright, it's time.
Doki items disappearing too.
Kill one.
Oh my god.
I got knocked down.
Alright.
Doki killed one.
Okay, I gotta kill midair and I die, that's fine.
There's one!
Let's try it.
I walked off?
Oh shit.
What?
Our points are good, our points are good.
Yeah, we got second though.
Did we?
It's like, I walked off?
I guess I walked off.
I think I got a kill as soon as I thought I died.
So in my head I was like, oh shit, I'm dead.
And then I just started running around and I guess I walked off.
I'll do my best.
I'll do my best, you know me.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, shorting your elite third is crazy.
That ice fight was some Looney Tunes shit right there.
The ice is not smart for points.
Because the kills take a year and a half.
Some fucking Looney Tunes shit.
Beautiful gameplay.
Is there a kit that does more damage with strafe?
Maybe like a...
I don't actually know.
I mean, you can use the axe kit down there.
But no, the ice is good to go in a minute later than we did.
The first two rounds it was actually smart.
The third one, I kind of panicked.
Because we were getting jumped and I wasn't with you guys.
So I told us to go to a safe spot on the ice.
And it worked, but...
Wait, I lost my second?
Oh, I forgot.
It's chill though, I'm in third.
Oh my god.
It's fine, it's fine.
It's like cool and chill.
What am I?
I'm 19.
Oh my god, how did I drop even more?
What did they do?
We're all top 20 though.
Yeah, we're top 20.
I'm 64, he's going to beat me in Raze.
Raze in blue and purple are a little scary.
Dude, SageMommy13th is awesome.
That's insane.
Let's go, Jas!
Bye-bye!
JoeBotBottomFrag is team awesome, hold on.
This is epic.
I love looking at the individual boards.
Wait, how do you look at the individual scores?
There's like an NPC next to the leaderboards.
And you can right-click it.
And it'll show you like in chat.
Oh, in chat!
I can just scroll up.
I was like wondering.
Hold on, JumperWhoOutFragXShatter?
Guys, I'm not last.
There's 40 players.
I'm like average.
Let's go!
I'm like in the middle.
Guys, look at all the actual Minecraft streamers.
I'm better than.
Let me actually check the leaderboards.
Wait for the individual games.
Oh my god.
I think someone needs to humble her real quick.
No, no, don't do this.
Don't do this to me.
I want to feel good.
I want to feel good about myself.
No, I think you should be humble.
No, please.
Please, I've suffered enough.
Oh yeah, we have a break right now.
So if anyone needs to like eat or is hungry or whatever.
You can take care of that real quick.
Oh man, maybe we'll get yogurt.
Yeah, I got food.
Oh my god, if Zan didn't kill steal me.
I would be first in battle.
Like I'm printing out someone in diamond armor.
And they take like a heart to hit.
Because they're full diamond.
So I'm just running for like 20 seconds.
And just runs fully into another team.
Like what do you want me to do in that situation?
So one HP and I get the kill steal.
And I get nothing.
So sad.
How many more games do we have left?
Four.
Maybe five.
If we get top two.
Four more games.
Because games have been like super fast though.
You know what?
I'm getting a bowl of yogurt.
Let's go.
So we have left...
We have race.
We have extraction.
We have party.
And I forgot the fourth one.
Blizz Hunt.
The best game.
You gotta go to the Krusty Krab.
Blizz Hunt is literally hide and seek.
It's awesome.
No, no, no.
Fine.
Do you remember what I told you?
People still know about it is the problem.
Yeah.
We just gotta manifest it.
So like for hide and seek.
Is the map like a new map?
Or is it like prop hunt where people just know where all the hiding spots are?
They add new rooms a lot.
But there's like...
They do a change of rooms.
It's pretty hard to memorize stuff.
There's like...
There's historically a skippity toilet spot.
That was really good for like three or four seasons.
Because it was just like...
Weird part to get to.
And you also had to look up.
So even if someone saw you.
Which most of the time they wouldn't.
You had to...
They just wouldn't know how to get to you half the time.
But now...
Everybody knows.
So it doesn't work anymore.
And I'm kind of developing roof gang.
As the next spot.
But I...
It's yet to be seen.
There's a room with a lot of buildings.
That just has like...
Two roofs on the build limit.
And like...
You have to parkour to get up to it.
And the parkour is not that hard.
But you have to very intentionally do the parkour.
So you can see yourself getting chased.
And also...
People have to look up.
Gamers don't look up.
We all know that.
The room is kind of new.
Gamers don't look up.
Roof gang could be the next god spot.
There's also...
A couple of patented strats.
Most notably...
Shit room theory.
Or skibity room theory.
Skibity room theory?
You hide in a terrible spot.
Objectively.
A terrible spot.
In one of the four rooms.
Close to the center.
Maybe the first turn.
But you abuse the fact that...
Why would anyone hide in this spot?
They're gonna check the corners.
They're gonna check the weird stuff.
They're not gonna check the house in the middle.
Skibity room spot.
It's better to send something like that.
And then there's always the center room theory as well.
You can just wrap up.
There's a lot.
Blitz is a great game.
Everyone who says it's all luck doesn't understand it.
For the hide and seek...
You have to catch you too, right?
Afterwards.
I wanna say a minute and a half.
Your name tag is hidden.
And they just have to...
One shot you.
And you can see them glow.
You'll see them glow through walls.
And when you're hiding, you can see the runners glowing.
So you can move around a corner.
If you see them coming.
You can leave a room if they just left it.
And you wanna play around like that.
They do have an ability.
I think they can use it every 20 seconds.
It just tells them how many people are near them.
It doesn't reveal you glowing at all.
It just tells you how many people there are.
So if you're sitting in a corner and they use it.
It'll say one or two if there's someone else next to you.
It's honestly probably good.
And I should use it more.
But it doesn't reveal the people.
So I feel like it doesn't really matter.
It could help.
I think it helps the most when it says zero.
And then you just leave.
That's what I think helps the most.
It's better if you're at the very end.
So you're deciding to run through rooms or sweep that room.
That's really it.
Oh, I'm learning.
I'm gonna get confident.
It's just God tier.
I see.
That's interesting.
What's the next game that usually people vote for now?
This one's Twitter.
I forgot about that.
It's just random and I don't care.
Oh my God, it's gonna be Blitzhunt.
Usually Blitzhunt's late.
But that's good.
People voted.
It's because you guys all talked about Blitzhunt.
So everyone's like, we might as well.
I guess.
We forgot.
I say we.
I forgot to mention that there's a Twitter poll.
We could actually probably influence the vote a lot.
It's because it's whatever's the second most.
And then Twitter API always lags.
So it is just kind of effectively random.
You can get it done like a 50-50.
If you vote for Twitter.
The way we were doing it last time.
Purple would get on the mic.
And he would just go, okay.
Everyone born in January and April 1st.
That's crazy.
He would separate my birthdays.
I was like, you're crazy.
But it worked.
We actually made it work so many times.
Oh.
What?
That's a bad joke.
I'm so sorry.
If you don't respond.
If you don't click ready.
Oh, it does.
Okay.
Because he's making a sandwich.
I understand.
I already had my sandwich.
I'm eating it now.
I should have been prepared.
I already ate my breakfast.
At 7 in the morning.
And then I went back to sleep.
In the spawn.
There's like a scary.
Version of the mascot.
At the top.
I saw him.
It was in the.
It was in the CGI.
Wait, where?
It's going crazy right now.
Oh my god.
It's Halloween themed.
I'm ready.
Gumi, what the fuck was that discord message?
Oh.
You gave me no context.
Oh my god, he's going crazy right now.
Maximum spinach.
Can I just reply?
I love graham crackers.
I love Minecraft.
I love MILFs.
I agree with all three of them.
Would be a crazy combination.
Graham cracker, MILF, graham cracker.
Oh man, I have ideas.
I'm looking good Saturday.
Why are we pausing?
Is somebody still eating?
Oh.
Red team is just hating on playing the games.
Red team hates Minecraft.
If they keep not responding time.
You should just take points away.
I agree.
I mean, you could literally do that right now.
What?
Well, I don't have admin firms.
They take away my admin firms when I...
How can they take away your admin firms?
You're literally the creator.
You're gone.
Well, I don't make everything.
I make some of the parts.
You should pretend you made all of it.
Yeah, you should take all the credit.
Be a real CEO.
And my logo on everything.
Renaming the event the Wolfy Wars.
Exactly.
You should put your own name on it.
It's all about the branding.
Exactly.
I should have paid more attention in marketing class.
I'm failing here.
Maybe I get more nervous for this game than I do.
Really?
Do you get nervous for this game?
I get tingles, man.
Do you get tingles?
I've never had a bad experience.
I'm scared the one time I have a bad experience.
I don't even know where to go.
I know it's in this game.
Brain turned off.
I sit in the corner and I'm right.
You tap out and then you're like, alright.
I'm just fully locked out in this game.
Okay, so there are north, south, east, west rooms.
And then there are corner rooms.
I don't know where to go.
No, no, no.
I'm going west.
You can try it.
My friendship's over.
I'll commit.
They know.
I'm going west.
Wait, there's nobody going east.
Why is no one going east?
Everybody's going west.
They saw the skibbity room.
Is east a skibbity room?
South, south, skibbity room.
This is going to be phenomenal gameplay.
Hold on.
Oh, no.
Oh, huh.
There's a hole.
Okay, there's a spot.
Actually, that's going to blow.
I'm no longer going to skibbity room.
I'm leaving.
Where am I?
Oh, there is a hole in it.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I might be the first one caught.
I might be the first one caught going up the skibbity toilet.
Ain't no way I get gunned for first.
That's crazy.
What is he doing not in the corner?
He just randomly decided, Hey, I'm going to go do this random parkour jump and check behind the tree.
Like, there's people literally in the sky visible.
Okay, whatever.
It's fine.
It doesn't matter.
It's chill, actually.
Oh, no.
Rootberries.
Center room theory.
Not working out for him.
Parkour on the prowl here.
Can't see them either anymore.
Dude, my tree has treated me well so far.
I'm just kidding.
Wait, you're in the same room I was in.
This is rigged.
Oh, never mind.
Laguna doesn't look right.
Hold on.
Everyone else on the team is cooking, though.
Goomy's in the cube, whatever room.
I'm employing center room theory here.
Are they going to clear the center corner?
Doki's just in the gamer spot, clearly.
Dang, taken out by parkour here.
20 seconds left.
This is where I died.
No, no, no, you're good.
Okay, your time is limited.
No, you might be okay.
You might be okay.
Stick.
Wait, he didn't see you.
Believe.
Oh, he's going to go.
No, he's not.
Zero!
We did it!
David's still locked down, either!
Oh, we're hunting.
Okay, okay, okay.
Just run around and try to check the corners and you can use your eye ability thing.
I'm going to go south at the start.
Everyone just get walled.
Everyone split.
I'll go west.
I'm going to go north and head west.
Doki, you can go with Giga.
Okay, there you are.
Go north and then you go right.
I'll go north and I'll go left.
I'll sweep that room.
No center room.
You can see people go in the center from here.
With the darkness, you can see.
Yeah.
I'll do a mid-sweep at the end.
People usually move to mid.
They do?
I just stuck in the corner.
Check the left side of this room.
Oh, I see you.
I see a gamer on me.
She's just running away.
How did I not hit him?
You see that girl?
There's a bunch of people.
We did it.
There's someone running towards mid.
I got another.
Nice.
Hold on.
I found Cam.
Where did he go?
Oh, there was another one.
Come back here.
Who is that?
He ran out.
Come on.
Huge.
Where did Cam go?
I don't know.
I'm just gonna ignore this room.
Oh, I should use my sonar.
That's what I've been doing too.
I found you.
Damn, that's...
Oh, there's a player near me.
And I missed both of them.
I got another.
Hold on, come back.
There's someone here.
What is this?
I got one.
I got three.
I'm getting tossed around right now.
I'm getting tossed like a fish.
Come back here.
Fuck.
I'm whiffing on the parkour.
Okay.
I'm getting the people who are not parkouring.
Okay, we did pretty solid, I think.
I got seven.
I got three.
I also got seven, apparently.
I saw a player head in the room and I didn't know if it was an actual player head or a person.
It looked like a placed Steve head or something.
Oh my god, this is Roof Gang.
Is this the actual one?
If you want to test Roof Gang North, you have to remember how to get out.
This is not the Roof Gang one.
Oh my god, it's not Roof Gang.
Panic.
What the fuck is this room?
I'm so scared.
I'm just going in here.
This room is terrible.
This is such an awful way.
Oh, that just didn't go my way.
Oh, that's awesome, actually.
This room is awful.
Terrible idea mode.
I might be dead, guys.
Wait, this is that?
There is a Skibbity Toilet Room.
It just said it in my head.
Dude, I see the god spots in the Skibbity Toilet Room.
I'm coming, I'm coming, I'm coming.
In the Skibbity, I see somebody in the Skibbity.
In the Skibbity.
Are you on the other side of the map?
I don't know what direction it is.
There's someone literally in the Skibbity.
I'm not kidding.
You can go in the Skibbity.
Oh no, Keegan, no.
The hunters aren't looking at you.
I can just run around.
Just in the middle, just chilling.
Yeah, they're not going to check anyways.
What does it matter?
I'm hunting now.
I'm hunting for the hunters.
They don't see me.
Oh, they saw me.
Oh fuck, never mind.
Oh, he's on you too.
Oh no, please.
I didn't mean to.
Please, I didn't mean to be here.
I think he saw me.
Oh, I just ran into all of them.
No!
Oh my god.
Wait.
I need to know what room this is.
Oh my god.
Don't smell me.
This is insane.
Skibbity room meta is insane.
True Skibbity.
We should have all went to the Skibbity room to get there.
They killed so many people.
We should have all went to that room to get there.
I didn't notice it was so late.
Is it still there?
Is the Skibbity room still there?
It's random.
Mushroom, right?
Mushroom, get it?
It's a mushroom.
Oh my god.
I'm going to go stealth.
Oh fuck, we started.
Okay, hold on.
I'm checking for Skibbity.
No, but there's a basketball court.
Hello.
I'm going to be balling on him.
Okay, this room is kind of trapped.
I'm sort of...
I don't have a hiding spot.
I'm just existing.
If I die, I die.
I tried a trapdoor flick.
I don't know if I would get yelled at for that.
But it didn't work anyways.
Okay.
I mean, surely they won't check, right?
Gamers don't look up.
Oh, he's looking up right now.
Oh, he is looking up.
Oh, you are being looked at.
Upwards.
Now how the fuck did that happen?
How the fuck did he just decide, Hey, let me check behind the box on the other side of the map.
Okay, nevermind.
It's fine.
It's okay.
This is not good for me.
This is really scary.
There's like 20 million people in this room.
What the...
Dude, not good for me.
Not good for me.
What the hell, bro?
Not good.
Hold on.
I see Giga is just chilling inside of a box.
Do they know?
Oh, they know.
Oh, I'm lucky.
It got slowed down right there.
Unfortunate, but...
Let's see the other squad.
Crazy.
Hold on.
Do they look?
They don't look back.
They just don't look.
Anthos.
We live, Giga!
I died.
You guys are alive.
You guys are alive, though.
They're just running circles.
It doesn't matter.
Oh, no.
Gumi not spotted.
Yes!
Let's go!
I live at the last second!
Holy fuck, man.
This game gets such and such a rush, bro.
Oh, man.
At the last second.
Oh, no.
Thunder's ahead now.
I'm gonna head north, too.
I'm fine.
I am south-gang right now.
Call it out if you get Skibity.
I just...
It'll be good, but...
I'm locked out.
I'm fully locked out.
My brain needs to turn on.
Oh, wait!
Spongebob!
Wait, what?
Yeah, I'm in the sponge room.
If we die, we both die together.
Holy shit, this room's bad!
Holy fuck, this room's bad!
I'm with a Thunder teammate.
I will bring this Thunder teammate down with me.
There's spots in the whole room!
Oh, no.
Dude, I'm in like a 1x2.
What is this?
I don't think I'm in a good spot.
Okay, I'm risking my life.
Surely they do not check in here.
Nope.
Okay, yeah, I'm good.
I'm with a Thunder teammate, so like...
I will bring down the Thunder teammate with me.
There's a Thunder teammate who died right below me.
Oh my god!
I see a cliff!
I see a cliff in the grave!
Oh my god.
Dude, I am so Karuza'd right now.
Oh no!
I was in Patrick's house.
I'm in a 1x2.
I'm in like the exhaust of the Krusty Krab.
Wait, this spot that Firebreath Man is in is so good.
I'm hiding in his fucking hitbox right now.
We both go down together, Thunder.
Oh no!
You died?
Dude, look at the spot that Firebreath Man is in.
It's next to the Krusty Krab.
It's opposite the little thing.
He's a Krusty Krab?
Oh, I see him.
You see that?
Oh shit, that's really good.
That's really good.
Look at Joe.
I'm in a really good spot.
Hold on, what's up squad?
I'm inside him.
Yay!
What's up squad?
You hurt?
Oh, I see, I see.
Holy shit, there's still three more rounds of this?
Everyone has to go.
Oh my god.
I don't recognize the room I'm in.
This is new.
I'm gonna go to the new room.
Maybe it's goated.
I'm tired of hiding already.
It's too much pressure.
It's too much.
It's freaking me out, man.
Ice room?
Okay, I don't know where to hide in this new one.
I'm just gonna wing it.
What the hell is this?
What the fuck?
Where do I even go?
GG, I lost.
Okay, I'm just...
This is really bad.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
I thought I was being really clever, but I'm dead.
Please don't go up, please don't go up.
We're good, we're good.
Goodbye might be the first one eliminated.
No, you're chilling, you're chilling.
No!
He turned around!
He actually did!
I was like, no, this is the dumbest thing I've done.
Wait, don't look at my spot!
Wait, where are you?
I was in the same room you were in.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Surely they can't find me, right?
Wait, what is...
What is this?
Gumi, what the fuck?
Gumi!
I'm not Gumi!
I'm JCB.
You can't fucking hide in this room, man.
I'm dead, but I see your little stupid guy and you are...
You are up in this room, I'll tell you that.
This is crazy, I'm hiding behind a one-by-one wall.
This is insane.
Where are they?
Can you not move when you die so I can scout?
For like a second or two?
This spot is crazy.
I've been detected.
Oh, boohoo, man.
Unlucky.
You're in the wrong room, buddy.
Good luck.
I gotta find this spot.
Don't move for a second.
Go, go, go.
Fine, your fucking spot is crazy.
Oh my god, yellow team had everybody alive.
Yellow team, everybody was alive.
Let's see if we can find some shit.
I don't like any side.
I don't like at all.
I'm gonna go west and then left.
I'm gonna hide with Thunder Person and fuck them over.
I believe in west and then left.
What the fuck is this?
Oh no.
Skibity toilets, but they are aware.
For the culture, we have to, I feel like.
The actual Skibity toilets?
What the fuck is my spot?
Jesus Christ.
This is crazy parkour needed to get here.
Hello?
I'm dead.
These guys know the spots.
For the culture, we're giving someone 100 points if they find us.
100 points if we get found here.
A solid 5 bomb.
I lowkey wanna run over there.
I'm not gonna lie.
I won't because I have a good spot.
It'd be so funny.
A solid 5 bomb.
Wait, is there two people on you?
Is that you?
I think...
I don't know if I'll live.
Wait, I'm shifting.
I'm perma crouch.
You're 1.5 blocks in this hole.
Oh shit, wait.
You have another lick teammate there.
Do I?
I don't think I do.
I think so.
Maybe it's lick perspective.
No!
He found me!
He turned around!
This team doesn't know!
This team didn't know!
He's getting toilet spots!
This motherfucker was at the top of the...
How is he so high?
Oh my god, wait.
There's another skippity toilet.
How is there so many people in here?
If someone came into skippity toilet room and found this spot...
No, no, no.
There is someone else in your room from our team.
There's so many people in there!
I think it was gooby.
Gooby was at the bottom.
I was in there, yeah.
It was just bugging on my spectate.
Okay, wait, wait.
Fine, fine, fine.
Follow me, follow me.
Come east.
Trust, I have a spot.
It's insane.
This spot is crazy.
We all die.
It's funny, it's funny.
It's on top of the hill, right?
No, it's on top here.
Go in.
In this fucking pipe, there's like a trap door that you can stand on.
And you're just hidden.
It's crazy.
Lower trap door, lower trap door.
It's hidden.
You have to walk one lower.
You can fall one lower.
It's in the back, it's in the back.
This side, this side of the back.
Stop trying to get in, though.
Because they'll see us.
Just stay still, just stay still.
No, they haven't.
They have not spotted us.
No, he's not going to look in here.
They saw me, they saw me, though.
They saw me, though.
OG Skidding Toilet of Ra.
Chapter 2.
This is lower expanded.
Chapter 2 Skidding.
And it's looking so good.
It's insane.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm alive?
How many of us are here?
I got away?
I just see you guys highlighted up in the Skidding Toilet.
I'll have to get a clip of that.
Oh my god.
Shane keeps dying.
It's just unfortunate for some people.
I got away?
Gamers don't look up, though.
They don't check.
Look, he's not going to look in here.
If you look up, then you have to look down.
And when you're in the room, everyone's like, you have to check Skibbity, you have to check Skibbity.
Look at them checking Skibbity.
What noobs.
Someone was actually up there.
They won't look.
You guys are so safe where you are.
This is chilling.
Are we all surviving?
I'm so sorry.
We did, man.
That is my bad.
This team works on their fucking searching.
I had the greatest escape, and then we all go to survive?
Oh man.
We pretty much tied first.
The blink gap is nothing.
Oh my god.
This game is so good, man.
I love BlizzCon.
Okay, now every game now is a multiplier, by the way.
It's like small multiplier first.
It's a 1-7?
Maybe 1-6.
500 points for BlizzCon.
It's a skill-based game, man.
I love gaming.
It's just a skill-based game.
We are exactly a thousand points ahead from second.
That's crazy.
I can't believe it.
I didn't see the room with the garage in it.
There's this one room where you can go into the garage and like get up in the back somehow?
I didn't see it once.
I wonder if it's still in there.
I just had like the greatest escape just to get fucked over by the caster curse.
My bad, guys.
Oh, Wolfie, holy brother.
The gap on this leaderboard is something.
Oh, wow.
Holy brother.
Shane probably genuinely got 150 points.
Wait, but there's a multiplier now, though.
It felt way worse, I'm gonna be honest.
Oh, I ranked up!
Let's go!
I'm 18th now.
Alright, guys, look at all the Minecrafters I'm better.
Damn.
Wow.
Look at these guys.
I'm a laughing fire breath man by exactly one tiny point.
Should've been better at the game.
Hey, man, one point's a pretty big gap, dude.
I mean, he's gonna beat my ass in race, so that's when it's over.
That's the one point?
I mean, that's gonna be more than one point, probably, but like, you know.
Today could be your day, who knows?
Last time we pretty much tied, because EU ping diff, you know, makes up for the one tick difference.
The one tick.
Literally one tick.
He beat me by one tick.
That's crazy.
So, EU ping diff makes up for it.
I technically beat your ass.
That's how it works.
We're just playing party last.
I'm mentally invested in playing party last.
I'm down for that.
Party seems really fun, too.
It's risky, because we don't know half the games, but I guess everyone doesn't know half the games.
Yeah, like no one does in this.
We don't know, they don't know.
And I absolutely do not know.
Mm-hmm.
Whoa, how'd that person have a boat?
Wait, where?
Click on the ice.
Can?
Where?
Just all on the outside of the hub.
You can just click on the ice.
Oh!
Is there like an invisible wall we can't go past a certain area?
No, you'll just fall off and it'll keep you back.
Oh, okay.
You can just boat off if you wanted to.
Oh, I couldn't even boat off.
Okay, uh... I mean, I say we go race, but I don't think it matters.
No, man!
Oh my god, my heart.
I glanced off.
I read extraction as construction.
So, like, we can have less multiplier when we do it now, right?
Oh my god.
I only see extraction.
I only see one sign.
That's my cat.
Why is it named Feinberg?
Why is my cat...
It's construction!
This is supposed to be my cat.
Oh, it's because you're dead, so I, like, reborn you as a cat.
Where are my cats going?
Oh, my cat got reborn.
Vote for race.
I think it is going to be race.
Yeah, it looks like it's going to be race right now.
I don't even have any signs.
Yeah, it's race.
Alright, there we go.
What the...
Ouch!
Race time, race time.
Bruh, they love extraction late.
It's always, like...
It's just a really good game to them.
I guess, yeah.
Honestly, yeah.
I don't know how good we'll be at it.
Okay, how do you play this?
It's a race.
You run...
It'll explain, like, the different movement things.
Like the jump pads and stuff.
Yeah.
With a little guy on the screen.
It's going to be the sickest video you've ever seen.
I'm not going to throw the trident section.
It's not going to happen.
Easy pad, hard pad.
If I go 1 for 3 on the tridents, it's better than last race.
Tridents?
Oh.
Yeah.
That's okay.
Tridents.
All good.
Do your best.
This is the jump pad.
And then this is the launch pad.
Jump pad goes straight up.
The green pads go straight up.
The red pads go, like, diagonal up, forward.
And then the pink pads is just running.
You don't want to jump on those.
Wait, so which pads are jump again?
The red and the green big ones are jump.
The pink ones are not.
Green, jump, red, far forward.
Red and green, you want the space bar on pink.
Okay.
Red, green, jump.
Trident, be in water, hold right click, and then let go.
And you'll launch.
Okay.
Understood.
Oh, it's banger song time.
Hold on.
I love this song.
Wow.
This shit gets me locked in.
Oh.
I'm ready.
You want to, like, sprint jump when you don't have speed.
Wait, where did everybody go?
Everyone's invisible, so you can actually see what you're doing.
Oh my god.
I walked back because I got so confused.
It's already over.
I missed the elytra hole.
It's over.
I didn't realize.
I missed the elytra.
I didn't realize everybody's invisible, so I walked back.
Oh no.
I was like, did I walk the wrong way?
Okay.
Ice boat time.
Or maybe not.
Oh god.
Oh Shane, good ice building, man.
Looks like you're in second now.
That's crazy.
That's the boat labs, brother.
Oh god.
Oh my god, I'm so...
Oh, I'm fumbling.
Fumble Nation is back.
I'm playing for, like, 15th right now.
That's the direction you're looking.
The boat is fucking me up, guys.
I don't think I'm a boat person, I realize.
What?
So over for me.
Okay, Skiff Nation is back.
I can't believe I'm in 10th after all the fumbling I just did.
That's crazy.
That's insane.
Hold on.
Guys, I'm not last, guys.
I'm only in 7th.
Bigger.
Huge, actually.
Larger.
Especially everything I went through.
Oh my god, we both fumbled the ice boat.
Or it's just weird.
You know, it's just weird.
Oh, fuck.
I fumbled the beginning and I'll never recover.
It's so sad.
Oh, that's what you do.
I'm, like, learning this race as I go along.
Yeah.
I'm surprised I'm even, like...
in this...
You got this.
You win these.
Oh my...
glob.
I think you and Shane are very far ahead, fine.
Because I'm with the whole squad.
No, Kevin's on 3rd.
Is Jojo close to you in 4th, though?
Yeah, I'm fairly sure.
I've seen Jojo around a lot.
There's literally a group of, like, 5 all together here.
Yeah, I'm, like, 10th.
Shane and Kevin are kind of far ahead.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, what?
We have, like, actually a group of 5 just chilling in ice boats right now.
Okay, okay.
Yay, 37th!
Let's go!
No loss, no loss.
GG.
Wait, what?
Oh, I don't know how to do this section.
Dude, the Neo's so fucking weird.
Why do I...
I have no confidence.
Oh, lucky bro.
Oh, I saw Xshatter faceplant into a wall.
Unlucky, bro.
Oh, cam man.
Oh my god, I inventory jammed.
My trident didn't work there.
Oh, he doesn't know how to skip.
Wait, GG.
Oh, you win these.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Wait, how do I get back up?
Shane's gonna be so...
Wait, where are you?
What?
I'm stuck.
You're so ahead.
I hate this.
If you're stuck, you can use the 9th inventory button and it should TP you back to your last record.
Wait, what?
Dude, same shit with the trident I just did, man.
What?
I'm a troll, man.
Okay, guys.
I am not doing this.
Guys, I'm like stuck here.
No, you got this.
I'm stuck in this water area because I'm confused.
Oh my god, cam man.
Nice try.
Hey, we're fighting for second here, man.
I'm like fighting for like range of 4th to 10th.
I don't know.
That's big.
That's big points if you clutch it.
I'm not clutching it, but I'm trying.
You can clutch it.
I'm stuck forever.
Oh, and Fumble Nation applied.
Like, what?
Applications accepted.
I got in.
Oh my god.
You passed?
I was just overqualified, honestly.
I was overqualified from Fumble Nation.
This was hell.
I was stuck in hell right there.
I figured it out.
I figured out what I did wrong.
Huge.
You fought through it.
I fought through the pain.
Who am I even...
Who is in front of me?
I think that's Jojo.
I fell.
It's over.
Oh my god.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, glob.
Oh, I know.
I got Loki, Saint, oh, glob.
I think, honestly, the worst part is just, I just don't know this math.
Yeah.
There's a lot.
Oh my god, his old ass can't keep up with me, surely.
Come on.
Goddamn, she's so fucking fast.
Back here, bitch.
Come on.
As long as I'm not last, everybody.
That's all that matters.
Oh, I miss my jumps.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
I'm 38th.
Let's go.
You got that?
38th in style, though.
Exactly.
Oh my god.
Nah, he beats my ass.
Unlucky.
It's chill.
We take that.
My last lap was a 9 second improvement.
Oh my god, that just shows how much I was eating dirt in the beginning.
That's actually a huge difference.
Yeah, that's crazy.
God.
We locked it down here.
We locked it down.
Back at it, Akko.
I think I see... Oh, Doki Bird coming in clutch.
I'm heading back.
I'm still on my...
I don't even know how many laps I have left.
Okay, that's lap 2.
That's all good.
You got it.
There's somebody who hasn't done a lap.
No, you have one more lap.
Oh, okay.
Someone hasn't finished a lap.
I don't know who it is.
I think I might know.
I don't know.
Where did I just TP to?
Okay, I think it's Toma.
Toma got 39th.
Oh, wait, did Toma get 39th?
It's Toms.
Yeah, I think it's Toms.
Toms is currently hanging out in the water.
Oh no.
It's unfortunate.
There's Rev going through.
I've locked in for 31st.
Oh my god.
You know what we should do, actually?
I hate the boat so much.
I mean, this is unfortunate.
This is pretty bad.
But it probably wouldn't hurt because the event is trending lower comp to have like a... you know how PD Voidbound lets you just run it for 30 seconds as a practice?
You should just do that with Trident and the boost pad.
Just some runaround thing.
Like how Battle lets you do the kits for a minute and a half.
I don't think it would hurt.
This would not happen.
Are you still watching?
I am watching.
I'm kind of curious about how the team is not telling them what to do.
Oh man.
Is Toma okay?
Toms is currently iceboarding.
Wait, I'm laughing her.
Get her ass.
I'm sorry, Toma.
Get her.
Hit those stairs.
I'm sorry.
And it's okay?
Apparently you can.
They're just going for the scenic route really at this point.
This is a really romantic route that they're taking.
I think they've given up.
I honestly don't think Toms cares anymore.
I think it's fair considering this is round one.
Yeah, it's chill.
Oh man.
I'm right behind you.
Surely there's no barriers.
No.
This person doesn't know the exit boat control.
Oh my god, it worked and I put him up.
We're not having to beat them.
Verdict up in the air.
Verdict genuinely up in the air.
Has their team told Toms how to sprint?
Like, hello?
Oh Jesus.
What's going on?
Oh my god, they're just like Jesus right now.
Yeah, they're actually like Jesus.
They're just walking in the water.
Is he okay?
It's gotta be a visual bug.
It's a visual bug.
Oh wait, there we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Big swing.
I've never been in this easy path before.
Yeah, I've never seen this before.
One ring.
Bang.
Handled.
Wait, what lap is he on?
One.
What happened?
Here's Tom.
Okay.
I think my downfall was when I got confused that everybody disappeared and I turned around and looked back.
Oh my god.
Alright, come on.
Let's hand it to Charlie.
They got this.
They're on the wall.
Nope, they don't want to go.
Okay, wait.
Maybe?
And then look up, right?
Yeah, surely.
Up there.
Insane.
GG.
Holy moly.
Alright, so Tom, skip to the left.
Boostpad to the left.
Skip and then hold left.
3 plus 1.
Yeah, it's light work.
Just do the skip.
It's not easy.
Did someone boost my cutover?
Oh my god.
There's another boat section.
Oh no.
I blame Booster for this one.
Lowkey, I think Booster needs to do some more teamwork here.
Honestly.
Wait, what happened to him in the last boat section?
They spent like 7 minutes.
And then they fell off entirely.
Wait?
See these like 3 block barrels where your boat goes really slow?
Yeah, they just launched it over.
They're doing it though.
Crazy, crazy movement.
I fucking struggle so hard on this.
Oh my god.
To the left.
You got this, Luffy.
Or not.
Nevermind.
Oh, oh.
Close enough.
Let's go.
And he did it!
Oh.
What does that mean?
Oh, that's what?
This person was going through it, guys.
Okay?
This person was going through it.
Look at this clean Elytra though.
Look at this clean Elytra.
Damn.
He's on team blue, right?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh shit.
Holy shit.
Team Fighters got so many points.
They did crazy.
I did not help out.
Not gonna lie.
With the points for that.
Is their ping bad?
Why did they get no jump on that pad?
Maybe they do.
I can't check.
Oh my god.
No!
You're gonna make it!
Maybe they do have bad ping.
You can't even let him finish!
You're not even gonna let this poor man finish!
Problems like West Coast.
So it shouldn't be that bad.
Something's not working.
Yeah, something's wrong with their thing.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Is he streaming right now?
Maybe if you spam jump on it, it's bad?
I don't know.
The jump pad definitely isn't working.
Maybe if you hold space, it's just doesn't work.
Let this man finish the lap!
He struggled so hard!
Big Tome of Hours, let's go!
Alright, Top's time.
Okay.
Uh-huh.
Wait, hold on.
Crazy.
Hold on.
No, no, no.
Just gotta slow down tactically.
Don't go too far.
Wait, does he have to climb back up?
Yeah, you have to, like, get to the end here and then climb all the way.
No!
Add time!
We did not convince the admins to add time.
Yay.
That's a great response after playing one and maybe a half lap.
Oh, we still got second?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Damn, okay.
There you go.
Yeah, Shane's disgusting, man.
Like, what is that, bro?
What is that, bro?
I don't know.
Uh-oh!
It only shows one fastest lap per person, so it's respectful.
Otherwise, um...
My placement is definitely going to fall from that.
Yup!
17 seconds results in 28 individual points.
My individual leaderboard is going to get absolutely blasted.
We're still over a thousand ahead, which is great.
I mean, fighters got the points, and fighters were, like, in the bottom, so it doesn't really affect us.
Doki!
This is a competitive game.
It is, like...
Second is up there, man.
Second is up for grabs here.
Okay, okay.
I mean, extraction could change a lot.
Alright, how much did that fall?
Oh my god.
I don't want to look at it anymore.
What I'm looking for!
I don't know!
Don't look at it!
Whenever we pick these back up...
I think I'd have to get zero points in party for this.
We're going to go crazy on party.
Alright, extraction.
Extraction's going to be fun too.
Alright, it's big gaming hours.
I kind of want to see an extraction right now.
I think party will be better at it, because it's a bunch of different stuff.
Party?
I don't like that the NPCs whip their head and turn to look at you.
Why?
Which NPC is it?
All the NPCs!
All of them?
Which one's the NPC?
They're just sassy.
Which one's the NPC and which one's fake?
The ones at the bottom of the leaderboard are the NPCs.
And then the rest...
No, no, no.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
Oh, they're like the leader!
To be toxic!
Toxic!
No, but the NPCs are in the theme park area.
Yeah, I saw some of them.
Oh, Wolfy's World!
Yeah, Wolfy World, that's what it's called.
By the way, I want to clarify.
I did not name it.
This is not my responsibility.
Sure, sure, sure.
That's what...
That's what Walt Disney would say, yeah.
The lore is...
We have a builder called Dynamite Donuts and he made an area called The Decision Donut after himself and then we went, that's kind of cringe.
And then he just made Wolfy World.
I was like, okay, I guess it's mine now.
What are we voting for?
Extraction or Party?
We should vote for Extraction.
Yeah, Extraction 100%.
Careful of crazy-ass bombs and shit.
Why haven't I got a different item than a cat this entire game?
Hey, you got cats.
So many cats.
I'm gonna vote people off so they can't vote.
I'm not letting you vote.
I'm not gonna let you vote.
Yeah, beat them.
You can't vote no more.
Get out of green.
Looks like we're playing Extraction.
I saw that.
Okay.
Good shit.
We're playing a map that very few people have played before.
Okay, so how do you play Extraction?
Oh yeah.
Extraction is crossbow.
You charge and then you shoot, but you can charge and run.
It's a 5v5 shooter game, basically.
It's a little arena shooter.
The crossbow, you have to like what we were saying, you hold right click to charge it, and then you right click again to shoot it.
It's not like a bow.
A bow, you have to hold and release and it'll shoot.
The crossbow, you like charge, you have to hold it to charge the arrow first.
And then once it's charged, you can click whenever you want.
Oh, okay, so you can let go after it's fully charged.
If you let go, it won't shoot.
You have to charge it and then click again.
Oh, so left click or right click?
Right click.
You'll figure it out.
You can use the first one to test it.
But the strategy is we're going to all go on one side of the map.
Every time.
We'll all call out which side we're going.
Because if this game like, if you are caught in a position where it's like a 1v3 or like a 2v4, you just lose.
It doesn't matter how good you are or how bad they are or whatever, you can't physically shoot more than one person at the same time.
Because you have to do the charge and then click again.
So we're just trying to overwhelm people.
Is the whole idea.
And I'll just call a side.
We'll go over to one of the sides.
We'll try to get this health up power up on the sides if you see it.
This health up thing on the side is just one free heart.
So we'll just try to have either me or Wolfie or whoever's closest try to just insta-grab it every round.
And then we'll just fight on whatever side.
And if we notice that there's a couple people out we'll just fully jump them.
Because again, you can't do anything.
And there's no friendly fire, right?
No friendly fire at all.
You can miss as many times as you want.
Every bun is four hits.
And every hit does one heart.
Everyone has four hearts.
Don't forget to extract.
If you don't extract in time, you don't get to.
We go right?
Yeah, we're gonna go right.
Wolfie, what's...
I don't even know what skin you are.
What spot are you right now from one to five?
Far right.
You can pre-charge it.
Okay, I'm gonna try...
One of you guys on the left line, there's a smoke bomb in mid.
You can maybe grab that on the way.
Let's just all go right.
All go right.
Okay, I get it now.
They're also going right.
I see some of them.
Oh, okay.
I shot one.
You can launch over some of these walls sometimes.
In the arc, it might still get them.
Oh, no.
I got hit.
Oh, I'm dead.
Holy...
Wait, what?
There's a guy behind us!
He flanked.
No, I got flanked.
I don't like how two of the colors are the same.
I'm trying to figure out the map.
A two?
A three?
Oh, my god.
One of me too, actually.
Oh, damn.
I think I don't like the colors that you're seeing.
Yeah, you were cooking.
I don't know if we can all crowd in the same area.
Yeah, I think we just need to go more aggressive on the side.
Like when we were poking around the wall and stuff, we just need to go more aggressive, that's all.
Otherwise, it's fine.
It's not as different than what I usually play.
The fact that we were the same color, I thought I was my teammate.
Oh, that's a good one.
Shatter's also very, very good.
Yeah.
Shatter's like, honestly, debatably the number one.
Alright, let's go right.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll grab the smoke bomb.
Purple versus lighter purple, yeah, that's basically...
Yeah, pretty much.
I was like, hey, teammate, and then I got shot at.
Okay, I got a smoke bomb.
Grab the heart.
Okay.
Two people on me over here.
Oh my god, I'm getting cross-mapped.
Oh, I'm so close.
I'm dead here.
I'm also low-key dying.
I'm dead.
Okay.
There's one solo on Gumi right now.
Oh my god, they like...
Oh my god.
They like ganked up on us.
Holy shit.
Damn.
I'm refining strategy.
Low-key, what if we go through mid?
I feel like mid's uncontested.
We can flank.
Yeah, and they all just split up on us.
Maybe this map is better for flanking.
Because you're in a hallway.
I think two right so you can do that little fork that split one on either side of it, and then three mid.
The only problem is we don't get the health.
Yeah.
We can maybe do like partial one side, then partial mid.
Maybe?
I don't know.
Because you want the health because it's just extra health.
You don't want them to have two extra HP.
Oh shit.
It's okay though, this is a learning experience.
Yeah, we're learning.
You could all rush the health and then split.
A couple go left, a couple stay right.
Yeah, yeah.
Like split into mid, right?
So you rush the health first.
Let's try to go left, and I'll try to do a mid flank.
Let's fight over the left area at least a couple times.
I'll try to flank mid.
I'll grab the smoke bomb as well.
Okay, are we contested here?
Yeah, we are.
I'm grabbing the health now.
Got it, yep.
Hit Lagundo, he's at two.
I am almost dead.
With extra health, I still got Lagundo.
That's crazy.
Oh, I got one.
I shot a lot on flank.
I think Parker's one.
In there.
Try to get some cover.
Cory's three.
Coming in.
One flank, one flank, one flank.
Yep, yep, yep.
Oh shit.
He's one on me.
I got one.
He's on me, he's on me.
Either one or two.
He's in the middle, I can't really ping him.
Yeah, nice.
Good job, good job.
Let's go.
Yippee.
We're figuring it out now.
We're figuring it out.
If you're really good in the charge, you can almost shotgun with the crossbow.
Yeah, it goes way faster than you would think.
I can only do it on NA ping though, I'm not gonna lie.
I keep getting diffed when people get on me.
That's fair, yeah.
I'll go for that flank again, I think it was okay.
I might join.
I flanked a little too and got a kill.
Yeah.
I got a lot of damage, I didn't get any kills, but I feel like I got a lot of pings.
Right, right, right.
Only four actually.
Oh, the charge is faster than I think.
Red team is cooking right now.
The points are crazy.
Let's go right, let's go right.
Let's go right.
Okay, I'll grab smoke bomb, or do you want to grab smoke bomb?
I'll grab smoke bomb, I'll grab smoke bomb and flank mid.
I'm gonna go down, so you guys go right top, I'm gonna go down like, can I ping that?
I'm gonna try to go down, I'm gonna do them down mid flank as well, you can come with me.
Okay, so we just have to hold these.
One's mid, one's holding mid here.
Oops, they got me once.
I'm just committing.
Oh, they got me too.
Oh, there's multiple in here.
Behind you, Motherfucker!
Right here?
Got one.
Oh, he hit me, but I might be dead.
One down, I'm dead.
Oh, I'm just blocking your vision, my bad.
I'm in their spawn.
This guy's going mid, around the left.
I don't know how much damage I got.
He's going left, he's going to you.
Oh, hello.
Okay, I shot him once.
He's going to your left.
Yeah, I just missed the cat.
He's going past mid.
I know I hit him once, at least.
She's in mid, left side over here.
I hit him once!
I definitely don't know the charge speed.
Nice!
Okay.
Large.
Yeah, I think the flank is 100% the play.
I beamed Joel down from max HP to dead in like 5 seconds.
He didn't see me at all.
I'll try to flank with you also.
We're the flankers now.
It's so map dependent, that's so interesting.
Are you left or right side?
I'm left, far left.
Okay, let's go right then.
Let's go right as a team.
You three hold the front lines, we'll flank.
It kind of works out.
Okay, this is the charge speed.
Cpk's hit once.
I have two.
Shot one, shot another one.
One on me.
Far right.
I'm like beaming them right now, this is insane.
We can flank them here.
Two dead.
Where's the last guy?
One more.
I see him, he's over there.
He's on me.
He's low, he's low.
Oh no, he's low, I hit him once.
He's one hit, he's literally one.
No, he's literally one!
Yeah, we have to.
What is that early extraction, brother?
I was trying to...
No, no, no, no.
I was trying to get the high ground shot.
Okay, that's okay, fine.
You saved it, you saved it.
I committed, okay.
Hey, we're clutching up though.
Yeah, we're figuring it out.
It's so map dependent, that's so interesting.
It makes perfect sense, but like...
We won our last three games, but we're still...
We're still like...
I think it's because...
The first two rounds, I think...
It's a lot closer than it used to be though.
Okay, let's go left.
I'm gonna go left and...
I'll go for the health actually.
I'll contest.
I guess they're also alive too then, so...
I got health, I'm coming back.
I'm just gonna go down.
Right, they're shooting across.
They're all right.
Giving them info, I mean...
They're right here, homie.
I hit Anne once.
Hey man.
Crazy bait.
I'm gonna bait him again.
Come on, three.
Oh, Shadow hit once.
Oh no, I got hit.
That was his three HP.
Linking action, huge.
Who's in this building?
Wolfie, come push.
One HP.
Two HP.
Oh my god, nice shot.
Two on you, Giga.
Behind you.
One HP.
Oh, behind me.
One HP in the middle in front of you.
He's on your left, right there.
You got him, he's one.
He's still behind that wall.
He's got the peak advantage.
I know you're both glowing, so...
He's gonna head toward me.
He's gonna maybe try to extract.
Just play the kill.
If he tries to go up, it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
He's going, he's going.
No!
That was so close, though.
That was really close.
That was close.
But he didn't get to extract.
Oh, we're third.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go.
In the middle.
I'm running.
I'm actually running.
Uh...
I'll go for the flank.
I'll come with you.
Oh my god, two under.
Smoking.
I can't help you.
I'm just spamming.
I can't see them.
I got MechaFox's two HP.
One HP MechaFox.
I'm literally on five of them.
I don't know how I got in this situation.
One MechaFox's one.
Zam one HP, Zam one HP.
Four in their spawn, four in their spawn still.
And one's wrapping you guys to the left.
I see him.
One's under.
I'm coming.
I'm going to go to their spawn.
One on me, one on me.
Oh, they're not in their spawn.
Oh, hello.
Nice.
One's high ground with me.
Above you right now.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Nice, good shot.
Um, one is on...
Oh my god.
Two's going mid.
Two mid, two mid.
Pick him in the sky.
Oh, they're going...
On the left, both together.
Oh, that was fun.
That's all good though.
Hey, last round, we were pretty solid.
We did good, we did good.
Good recovery from...
Oh, we take a six, that's good too.
It's not that much of a point gap though.
Yeah, the middle's all the same.
So map dependent, I guess, yeah.
Flanks just make sense.
Glad we switched it up.
I got 38 damage, I might be top 5.
Oh, shit.
And 11 kills, I might be top 5.
Oh my god, you're gaming.
I know.
They game even harder.
Oh, hey, we're still...
That's crazy how we're still first.
Oh, party game, let's go.
Party game time.
There's one in the middle.
Yeah.
I like that.
We can split, I don't know.
Oh, I got 10.
I got 14.
Dude, beat the MC, got 11.
Where was this last event?
What?
It's okay, not last, guys.
Oh, shit.
Rough.
I'm surprised by this board.
I did not expect to get fourth, but I guess fine brick difference, you know.
Brother, one more game, lock in.
Could be sixth.
We need to focus.
Is it we play both the...
The Splatoon and the Get Down for party?
Or...
It's like a few minigames.
Splatoon, the Go Down, we play...
Like Photon, which is like Valorant Deathmatch.
Okay.
And then we play Heist, which is like Payday.
Oh, so that's all in the minigames.
Oh.
Okay, okay, I understand.
We just do like one of each.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Do like all these...
Do like most of the games repeat for Block Wars?
Or like...
Uh, you mean like...
There's the eight here that we're playing.
There's Trailblazers, which is a movement type game.
Where you get to like choose what you're doing.
So there's like...
You have 12 minutes and it's just all individual.
And you can do like parkour, you can do elytra stuff.
You can do boat stuff, you can do trident stuff.
You can do block placing stuff.
It's like a race that you kind of get to choose what you're doing.
So it's kind of cool.
That's one of the games.
Another one of the games is...
Construction.
And...
That's just a building game.
And it's, I think, getting reworked.
Or recoded.
Or both.
Well, that's why it's a 2-2-1.
No comment.
And then...
I'm forgetting one.
I'm fairly sure that's it.
I knew it.
Guys, I'm not bad.
I'm just inexperienced.
Okay, guys.
Skyzone is dead.
I'm just inexperienced.
These maps come back, guys.
I forgot to vote, guys.
This is tragic.
I wonder what game it's gonna be.
What game are we gonna play?
I won a bunch, too.
Hey, guys.
I love getting people out of a 1x5.
This is like a mosh pit.
Oh my god, that's mosh.
All right.
Oh, this is a new hub.
I forgot they made a new hub.
Oh, yeah.
How are you doing?
We're playing Morse code on the screen.
What the hell?
Single Neo.
Holy moly.
Oh, yeah.
So, also...
Last game, the scores were hidden.
So, we won't be able to see how well anyone's doing.
Oh, I see.
Why did they make the triple Neo...
It's like an arcade.
We're in an arcade.
Why did they make the triple Neo, like, barrier?
You should actually have to hit it.
What do you mean they make it barrier?
Like, the ground is one block tall.
Like, they should make this, like, two down.
Over here.
So, if you're standing on the triple Neo...
You're like a pro, you know?
Like Fargo Master.
Like Fargo Civilization.
Right, right, right, right, right.
Oh my god, it's the construction guy.
Oh my god.
What's happening?
What?
Okay, is this all lagging for you guys or is it...
Oh my god, that's a lot of blocks.
Holy shit.
The camera couldn't even load those blocks in.
Oh my god.
Heist.
Everybody.
No.
They're all lagging on Discord.
Oh no.
What the fuck do I do with a stick?
What to do with stick.
What does
stick mean?
Oh no.
Oh, it's knockback stick.
Okay.
Get away.
Alright.
Wait, maybe PVP will be there immediately.
Who can we bully?
Let's go for blue team.
I'm gonna run at blue team with my knockback stick and stop them from entering the bank.
Oh, are we back?
Yeah, we're back.
Where do we deposit our money?
See this truck to the right?
With the arrow on it?
You go in there and you deposit.
You go in and the higher quality ore blocks you mine, the more points you get.
Higher up in the thing.
Do we run in?
Do we have to hit anything?
No, you just run in and you mine stuff.
There's gonna be mobs and I think we just knock back them away.
Get away.
So it's like when you spray holy water on the demons, you use that.
Don't let the demons get you.
That's pretty cool.
Let's go.
I'm gonna full send top floor if I die.
We're just waiting.
I'm just not even...
Do you know how long we have to play?
Probably two or three.
Between two and three, probably.
I don't even know if I readied it.
Oh, I did.
I think there's an overtime as well.
I think there's a 30 second overtime that you can use to get out.
Oh, it starts in 12 seconds.
Yes.
Do we have speed or not?
Probably not, right?
Yes, yes.
Oh, yeah.
You start with speed.
The more stuff you have on you, the slower you become.
Okay.
It's like a realistic weight mechanics.
Yeah, I'm also sending top floor.
That'd be funny.
Whoa, don't hit me.
I don't know where up is here.
I'm going up.
Yeah, this is just not where I'm supposed to go.
Never mind.
Oopsie.
I don't have any diamonds.
Oh, they're fine.
Now I don't know how to parkour this.
I'll just be the poor little iron girl.
Wait, maybe not.
Oh, hello.
Yeah, yeah, we can knock each other.
Yeah.
How did you get roof?
Is there just one path that I need to find?
I think it's in the back.
Oh, my speed has decreased so much.
Holy fuck.
Oh, that is a roof.
We're gonna head back now.
I'm just gonna go deposit now.
Honestly.
What is this place?
I'm lost.
That's all good.
Oh, there it is.
I see it.
Emeralds.
What the fuck?
Oh, I'm dead.
Okay, sick.
That's crazy.
The Ravager is insane.
Well, I just lost all my points.
That's awesome.
40% of your stuff drops?
Or something like that?
It drops it on the floor, but I just don't have anything anywhere.
I'm gonna go back and deposit now.
I got a diamond.
Oh.
I deposited 19 orbs.
Let's go.
That's gonna be my next wave.
Oh, golly.
I just got shot by a thing that was not...
Wait, what?
Oh!
Now I know why they were running.
Ow, ow.
Oh, my God, I can't.
Oh, my God.
All the mobs are gone, I believe.
Oh, there's so many.
No, I believe.
Oh, I need to get out so I don't die.
Hello, everybody.
Wait, are we still...
I don't know how to get out of here.
It's truly...
Oh, I died.
No, I had so much stuff.
Yeah, don't be greedy, guys.
Don't be greedy.
I'm taking what I got and brain that I can get out.
Don't be greedy, everybody.
Don't be greedy.
Just dodge and weave.
I'm gonna die immediately.
No, I'm out.
Dodge and weave.
Oh, it's cooked.
Holy fuck, there's like 40 of them in one spot.
I can't leave.
There's just a ravager in the fucking one doorway.
Oh, my God.
I scored 0 points.
I scored 0 as well.
I scored too.
I scored.
Oh, my God.
I got 236 in one party game.
Let's go.
I got 0 points.
Why is there one guy like right here just...
He's just...
There's one just guarding it.
Don't be greedy, guys.
That's raw points.
I'm in the barriers again.
I got 236.
That's crazy.
36.
Damn.
I don't know if I did good.
I got no points, that's so funny.
That's crazy.
It's just how I did the math.
There's like a pack of a billion of them.
Please give me go down.
Go down.
Splatoon time.
Dude, I was on one heart at the top for so long.
Fine, I was cooked.
I had points to go back.
The one path downward was blocked by a ravager and about 20 other motherfuckers over there.
And I just couldn't go there.
And then I ran back and there was another 10.
Where are we going?
Down.
Do we just spray?
It's time to goon.
You can hit each other.
You can hit other players.
We just start gooning.
Oh my god.
I'm gooning.
You can hit walls and ceiling.
How do we...
Out of ink?
Oh, it is like...
Splatoon.
You have to hold crush.
Freaking fire breath man.
Wait, I can die?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I would've been shooting in the beginning.
If I knew it's over for you.
If I knew...
I thought this was...
I thought this was just chill.
This fuck guy is going...
Beaming for my eyes.
Come back here.
Now that I know it's no longer chill.
I'm just covering all the high walls.
Do the buildings count too?
Like walls?
Yeah, every single block.
Oh no, he got me.
Jesus Christ.
Just get like high ground and start launching.
Yeah, I'm trying to grab the ones that aren't even inked yet.
Oh my god.
Oh?
Can kills like give us more ink?
Kills give just hella points.
Oh it does?
You do get um...
You actually get ink bombs for kills.
So it does actually give.
Oh shit.
I got like fucking ran at by 20 people.
I tried to 1v1 CPK and I died.
Dude, the fucking ink bomb used to do damage and they didn't.
They changed my game.
They ruined my baby.
They ruined your baby.
This is so messed up.
How could they do such a thing?
Player spotted.
It's fruit berries.
Hello?
What?
It doesn't matter.
It's fine actually.
I almost got him.
Come on.
Is that a good hit?
I'm going random spray around the map strat.
Just hold right click and start geeking on the spray.
No!
I got hit by behind!
The third parties!
Stop!
Oh my god, this Firebrand loves it.
Third parties should be illegal.
I got 22 kills.
Nice.
I got 5.
I actually think I'm getting bottom 10 this game.
It's crazy.
I'm actually destined for greatness right now.
Wolfie, what happened to you?
I got 0 points in heist.
Absolutely 0.
I got 5 kills here, which is alright.
I'm going to be right there with you.
Oh my god.
Wait, does it not tell you your points?
It only adds the blocks?
Well, we don't get to know points right now because it's like game 8 hidden scores.
Oh my god, new Photon map!
This map looks crazy.
Deathmatch!
Okay.
No, he saw me!
What the hell just happened?
I see fruit and I'm trying to crouch away from him.
Please, I'm a baby.
Don't do anything.
I'm just going to come up to you.
I'm turning up the music.
I'm going to die instantly here.
There's a guy right in front of me.
No, this is for people who love Boomer Shooters.
Trust.
No!
I had 2 people on me?!
I literally had 2 people on me.
That's actually...
I'm literally spawning into people.
Holy shit.
What the...
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, thank fucking god.
I was going to be so mad.
Oh my god, I killed a country soldier.
I died, okay.
Minot!
I'm winning.
Where am I going?
Oh, there's always someone behind me.
Yeah, no, that happens to me too.
Oh, nice.
Oh, get sniped.
Oh, come on, man.
Wait, what?
I can't find anyone.
What do you mean?
Okay, nice.
Oh, I'm figuring it out.
Behind me?
In front of me?
To the side?
To the left?
To the right?
That was me when I spawned in.
I know how you feel.
This guy's on the floor.
XShatter's cheating.
What is going on?
What?
Okay.
Oh my god.
XShatter is fully swimming on the floor while shooting.
When they spawn next to you, it's...
I keep trading with people.
That's crazy.
They killed me!
What?
I just...
I'm just...
I'm just hitting spawn camps.
Oh, just killed me twice in a row.
That's crazy.
I'm just hitting spawn camps.
Are you serious?
I can't hit him.
Okay, I got him.
I lurk away.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna freak out.
I'm actually gonna freak out if I get spawn camped one more time.
I'm gonna lose it.
I'm gonna fucking lose it.
Oh, okay.
I'm getting absolutely destroyed.
Oh, she plays very hard.
That's not fair.
I'm gonna go to their house.
What?
I'm on my way right now.
Oh, man.
I didn't even know he existed.
Oh, we're teamed up.
We're teamed up.
We're here.
Okay,
I know where people spawn now.
I just got 360, man.
Oh my god.
If I get spawn camp, we all get spawn camp.
I got 12 kills.
I got 12.
I feel like I could have gotten more if I didn't get spawn camp.
He didn't even have to say it.
That's the first time I ever told you.
The leaderboard speaks for itself.
This is part of the record, bro.
Honestly, you're kind of right.
Oh my god.
I have to pop off on go down.
I have to walk in on go down.
This is your game.
I hope that cam doesn't punch you off or something.
We're going to win go down.
I realized that the spawns are the same so you can literally just stay there and spawn camp.
So that's what I did.
It's dropper.
You have limited health.
You have to get to the bottom and stay alive.
When you die, you go back to the top.
You get nothing.
If you get to the bottom, you go back to the top and you just play again.
You can punch other people but it's so not worth it.
Points wise, it's so not worth it.
But I kind of want to.
Come back here, Joel.
I see you.
God.
The karma.
It's unlucky.
Oh my god.
Genuinely targeted.
That's crazy.
Change your skin right now.
It's high.
You can go pretty far down the first couple layers.
Yeah, I just found that out.
Also, when you hit a...
a new layer...
Oh god.
It heals you, right?
Yeah, it heals you.
Oh, that's big.
I made three insane mistakes and it just literally didn't matter at all.
Yeah, there's a damage reduction.
Oh, I'm live?
Okay.
Oh, Winston health pot.
Hold on.
I have a fishing rod.
Oh my god.
What's the tech with the fishing rod?
Oh no!
You grab somebody from up top and then you drag them and then they're gone.
Okay.
Okay, it doesn't reach.
We were friendly because you guys said it wasn't worth it.
Oh, I'm dead.
Okay.
Hold on.
I got to pink, but then I died.
I'm on pink right now.
Hold on.
Oh, there's a pig here.
No, no, no.
Let's go!
I did one.
Wait, I died?
What?
Oh, did somebody hit me in the back of the head?
Oh, I'm so dead.
Sometimes they do, yeah.
Oh my god.
Show Bart.
People keep hitting me.
I'm just running it down.
I didn't do it.
For the first couple, run it down pretty easily.
I see a pig.
Hold on.
Oh, I'm freaking eagling now.
Oh my god, I thought I was going to die.
Dude, dude, dude, who is this?
Kaboodle's just swinging my ass on the checkpoint.
Hello?
I'm alive.
Fuck you.
Oh, I fumble.
Fumble nation.
Fumble nation is so bad.
I couldn't get to the pink.
I did two laps.
Did I even do three?
Bro, I didn't even get to the bottom.
I did one lap.
I didn't even do a lap.
I was so close.
I got to the pink.
And then I got beat off.
Yeah.
It's time.
We'll see if we did good, guys.
I got beat off.
It's possible we could not be first.
It is technically possible.
Because I did absolute shit.
I had the best party performance that has ever been seen ever.
Yeah, but I like balanced it out.
It's cooked if I don't even get called on this leaderboard, I'm not going to lie.
I don't even care.
It's no big deal.
Yeah, I don't care.
Yeah, yeah.
We don't care.
It's no big deal.
Yeah.
Cheers.
Whatever.
Yeah, whatever.
Okay, that's good.
I only dropped two.
That's fine.
Alright, alright.
Damn.
Shatter went crazy.
I'm not going to look at them.
They don't deserve my...
Why do you keep inviting me back, man?
How do you keep getting away with it?
What?
How do I keep getting away with it?
This is just endive.
Now onto the leaderboards.
We crushed team.
Well, that's until I got no points in one of the games.
That gap is crazy.
Oh my god.
I can't even not look at it if I wanted to.
Wait, this is close.
It's so crazy for a lime, right?
Fruit should in.
It's red.
It's either red or...
This is so close.
Gulp.
Red or purple?
I think red did the most.
We're gonna be fine.
Alright.
Yay!
That's us!
We get to play Valorant.
Let's go.
We're in first!
We were.
Wait a minute.
Oh my god.
We got first.
Fun fact.
Red team has two Valorant players.
Okay.
I'm also a Valorant player.
I'm an Apex player.
Slash Overwatch player.
But I don't know how this game works.
They have two Valorant players.
A Minecraft player.
A Fortnite player.
And an osu!
player.
I'm 0 for 2 on this game.
So, I don't know what to do.
I'm sorry.
We just gotta shoot them.
How do you play this?
This is the one game I didn't read.
When you shoot someone, they get frozen.
That's like the main thing here.
So, you wanna just tap people.
Oh, is this freeze tag?
Yeah.
It should show in the tutorial.
Yeah, there's a charge.
You pick it up, you plant it.
Getting it planted early seems to be really important.
It takes a while to break it too.
So, if you can find a little corner to peek around to break it, it's good.
Because otherwise, they'll just find you and bam, you're done.
Alright, does anyone know the corners?
Does anyone know that?
I am not the plant.
I can't do the planting.
I don't know how to plant either.
I think Fine should do it since he's actually played this before.
Alright, Fine, you can't.
I'll do whatever, man.
I don't know how to play this.
See ya, Tom.
I don't even know what's good to start as, even.
Wait, there's like classes?
Well, you just start as attacker, defense.
Oh, okay.
Is this attacker or D-sided?
I don't know.
Alright, Wolfie, let us know as the organizer.
Is this attacker?
Is this D-sided?
I don't know.
We have the charge, so we're planting.
Oh, no, we get to choose.
Attack maybe on start?
I'm not sure.
Defense was really good, but I don't know how good it is now.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's a heart over their head and you like...
Yeah, I'm gonna lock attack.
Just cause I don't know, man.
Are you locking attack?
Rush B!
Oh, that's B!
Okay.
Yeah, I'm down to rush B.
It's closer, it looks like, maybe.
Uh, maybe.
We have pretty quick access to it.
I'm gonna try to flank.
I'm gonna try to flank through mid.
Wait, but who's planting?
Everyone should go B.
Wolfie, you can plant.
Okay.
Sorry.
Wait, but Wolfie...
I was gonna say...
I'm gonna plant over here.
This sprint is weird.
3, 3, 3, 3 rotating, 3 rotating, 3 rotating.
Got one.
Crazy pre-fire, by the way.
2 more rotating.
Oh, behind us.
Far flank, Shane's far flanking.
That's insane.
He was so good.
Nice.
Maybe defusing, Wolfie?
No, no, no, not defusing.
Good trade.
Nice!
Just play for bomb, play for bomb if you can.
Yeah, just wait for them to try and get the charge.
They're coming in now, on site.
Nice!
Let's go!
I forgot it was one shot because I saw all my hearts and I was like, I have plenty time to live.
Are we rushing B again?
Yeah, I'll do the same thing.
They'll probably expect it, but that's true.
I'm just gonna do it differently.
But you got the charge down so fast on B.
Yeah, I try to not plant it at the corner.
There's one in front, right in front of you.
Got him.
Nice.
Three down on site.
Is there fall damage or no?
It's just Shane on me, it's just Shane on me in the corner.
I'm just time stalling.
I'm coming for flank.
I got him, I got him, I got him.
Nice, nice, nice.
Holy moly.
Okay, we're defending now.
Go B!
Go B, go rush B!
He split surely, right?
I can maybe go mid.
Maybe we can have one A and then I'll B.
I'll go A, I'll go A.
Two split, two A, two B.
I'll go B.
I'll go A too then.
I don't know where they're going.
I don't know if they saw me.
They saw me.
They're B, they're B.
One down mid.
I'm down mid, that was not a great play.
Close on the wall, close on your wall.
Nice.
Nice trade, nice trade.
They're rezzing mid.
You should fight on the site right now.
I'm trying to get bomb A.
That's hard, that's hard.
I think attack was good.
I don't think mid is the play.
I don't think we need mid because there's only two points anyway.
Mid is just for location.
I was going to go for flank.
You can play mid and just watch them trying to flank us.
I'm going to go B, I'm going to go B.
I'll watch mid.
I'm rushing it.
This is attack sided, heavily.
I think.
I think they're going A.
B, I see two B.
Nevermind, I lied.
I spread misinformation on the internet.
Yeah, I'll come over to B.
Let's just take the fight.
They're not on site.
They planted the bomb.
I traded.
Yeah, they did plant.
Where's the other team?
Wait, where's the other team?
Hold me, hold me, hold me.
Behind, behind, behind.
I just...
Bomb, bomb, maybe last.
I'm going around the corner.
To your left, Doki.
Oh my god.
I don't know the chart for this.
Nice.
Diffuse.
Just hold it down.
I didn't know you had the...
What was it?
The charge up of the bomb?
Did we even kill all five?
I guess we did.
I guess we did, yeah.
Yeah, you have to get the charge up.
The chat's so weird because it overlaps between rounds.
You know what I mean?
Are we attacking now?
Yeah, we are.
Can we go A?
Because everyone's been going B.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can go to B just to bait them.
I'll bait on B.
Oh, you bait?
Okay.
Do we wait then on A or no?
No, no, just plant instantly.
I'm going to plant at a really bad spot.
I don't know this spot though, so...
Two flank, two flank, two flank.
One more flank, one more flank.
Resing the bodies, resing the bodies.
Two more flank, two more flank.
All three flank, all three flanking.
All five flanking, all five now up and flanking.
Maybe splitting up now.
All five back there, all five.
Okay, I see one.
Right here, right here.
On the bomb, on the bomb, on the bomb.
Yep.
Nice, good trades.
Oh, empty.
On me.
Nice trades, 2v2, 1v2.
On site, on site, on site.
Nice try, nice try.
Yeah, yeah.
Dude, I held flank and they were just like...
I got the first shot.
I think we should go B now after that.
I think so.
I think we swap.
I think we know B better than A.
Oh, we're defending, we're defending.
Oh, we're defending?
Okay.
Oh, it swaps 1-1-1?
Sure, sure, sure.
I'll go B then.
I'll go A.
They're just pre-firing by the way.
They're not even aiming anymore.
I noticed that.
I'll watch mid.
I think B is easier to attack.
It really is.
Uh-huh.
Uh, one mid.
I see them, I see them, I see them.
They're B, they're B, they're B.
They're pre-firing my area.
One is mid.
Got one.
One's on top of the spike.
There's three, there's three on B.
Oh, oh, one got me.
Alright.
Woah, woah, woah, one is in their spawn.
Hello?
Jesus.
There's two right where I'm shooting right here.
One's in their spawn, on you Doki, on your right.
How do I rez?
Oh no, I didn't know how to rez.
Is there one left?
Last one was on...
Yeah, there's one.
I didn't know how to rez, so...
I was trying to cover.
It's okay, it's okay.
I think we push B, fight B.
Yeah, just fight B.
Do we do overtime?
This is overtime.
This is the last one.
Push B, push B.
That's crazy.
I'll try to hold mid.
Very passive.
Yeah, I think we have to play passive.
I don't think we should flank anymore.
We have everybody here.
I'm gonna hold their flank, if anything.
We're starting fights as a 3v4.
On me.
On bomb.
Diffusing.
Diffusing in the corner.
Did you get him?
Nice, Feinberg.
I got...
One behind you.
One on site.
On that dark oak.
You can try to rez me, maybe?
You don't have to push.
Just keep them from getting charged.
I'll tell you if I see them getting charged.
You can try and rez.
Maybe not.
They're still around that box.
Can they rez?
Do they have any bodies on them?
I don't think so, right?
Zucky, just play time.
Still around that box.
On spike.
Fake, fake, fake.
Faking.
Push out, push out, push out.
You win.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Push, push, push, push.
He's pushing you!
I'm pre-fired.
He's pre-fired!
No!
Let's go!
I pre-fired that.
Huge clutch.
Let's go.
Jesus.
Good job.
Oh my god.
I don't think he even showed up on my screen.
It was just a good pre-fire.
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Thank you, Raid.
This is my first time playing Black Wars.
This is my second time!
Wolfie and I played a lot.
Dude.
This is the second time I even made Finale.
Huge win.
Let's go!
Enormous.
And then I never played Black Wars to be undefeated.
I want to see the leaderboard.
Let's go!
Winner POV.
It didn't matter that you trolled, man.
I'm telling you, it didn't matter that you trolled, man.
How do I get off this thing?
Yeah, how do we get off?
Guys, I don't want to leave.
Go through the back.
Oh, nice.
Please, I don't want to leave.
Exit stage left.
I'm stuck there forever.
First win for sure.
Team picture.
We should go back on the platform.
Get back on the platform.
Can you go back?
I'm lost.
We can.
I'm back here.
I'm lost.
What's the POV to make it so you're a third person?
F5.
How do I get back there?
Get back there.
Look at us.
I'm like a real Minecraft YouTuber.
We're Minecrafters now.
What's up, guys?
I have a barrier block in my way.
Awkwardly in the back.
Photos, guys.
Cheese.
We all did it.
Let's go.
That was fun.
Incredible team games at the start.
A 1k gap after two games.
Thanks for holding my hand throughout that.
That was...
I can't believe we did it.
Let's go.
Team game start was good for the mentality.
We had the winner mindset.
Yeah.
We had such a huge lead that we knew...
It was manifested.
GGs, everybody.
I had a great time.
Thank you for inviting me to participate.
That was great.
I'd love to do it again.
Now that I know the race.
I won't pause and turn around.
You should have seen my POV.
Where did everybody go?
I literally walked backwards.
GGs, guys.
GGs.
Great playing with all of you guys.
Of course.
It was super fun.
I love the high energy.
Even when you fucked up the bank thing.
We still did it.
I'm pretty sure I picked up your stuff.
Did you die with four emeralds?
Yeah.
I died top layer.
I'm pretty sure I picked up someone's stuff.
Technically, your stuff contributed.
You can take like a hundred on my end.
GGs, everybody.
I'm going to go talk to my chat now.
Have a great rest of your day.
What is it, Goomy?
Can we play Liar's Bar, please?
Right now?
Yeah, it's really good.
I have a stream at 5, but we can do it another time.
I hope.
We can do it next week.
Promise?
Yeah, I promise.
Do you remember that we're supposed to do the other game?
Yeah, I do.
I'm out of here.
Okay, see you guys.
Bye, everybody.
Thank you.
We did it!
We got first!
Let's go!
Okay, that Valorant fight...
That Valorant fight...
I need you guys to know...
I...
He wasn't even on my screen.
I just pre-fired.
Because he said he was pushing.
And it was...
It was a 50-50.
It was...
I won.
I literally won the 50-50.
I don't know if you guys saw that.
But like...
I didn't even see him on my screen.
Did you see him on my screen?
I didn't.
It was just an insane read.
Yeah, I just...
I read him because I was like...
Because they were all pre-firing.
I was like...
Wait, they're not even like...
I learned that they weren't even like...
They weren't even aiming.
They were literally just pre-firing.
So I was like, there's no point in me pushing up.
There was no point in me pushing up.
Because I had a feeling they were just going to rush...
They were going to run at me.
So if they're going to run at me, I'm just going to play Valorant.
And hide in a corner.
And...
I was just like...
If I'm going to be playing Valorant...
I'm going to be playing Valorant.
Like...
Thank you.
But yeah, it was really fun.
I'm really glad they invited me.
Invited me to Black Wars.
I had an incredible fun time.
I was learning everything as we go along.
So like...
I didn't know what...
Everybody else had a lot of experience.
So I was just like, what am I doing?
I was so confused in the race.
In the...
In the race and the...
The one where...
The extraction one was so confusing at first.
Because I don't use crossbows.
So I didn't know the charge up.
But we...
We did it.
I was so confused.
So...
I'm just glad we still got it.
We still won in the end.
We beat the Valorant team too.
We beat the Valorant team.
So that's all that matters.
Oh my god, that race though.
That race was fucking a disaster.
I'm so confused.
What the fuck is going on?
Because I can tell.
People here seem to have done this multiple times.
Like...
Everybody seems to know what's going on.
So...
We don't talk about that.
But...
I have...
We have a member stream tonight.
For Team Fortress 2 in 3 hours.
So I am going to prep for that.
I didn't tweet it out yet.
So I'm going to make a waiting for that.
There was no race in block wars yet.
But it was a great time with my team.
We did incredibly well.
I felt like the games were really fun.
Were really well designed.
And as always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.